Oh my god, are you an actual bad boy?
Yeah?
What's the baddest thing you've done?
Yeah, name five.
Yeah?
Oh my god, you're a god damn criminal!
You're god damn crazy!
That is hardcore, man.
Whoa!
That's...
That's messed up, man.
That's so messed up.
Like right off the bat?
Oh shit, you guys don't hear it?
You guys don't hear this sound?
Are these just too quiet?
There's no way you guys don't hear this!
Okay, I'm turning it up.
Yeah.
Wait, they said it in general?
You guys don't hear it?
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me fix this.
Oh, there you are.
No, no, no.
It's up to you.
You can continue streaming something else.
Oh, okay.
Glad they gave me that.
No, you have to end right away.
You have to.
Yeah, yeah, you just end it.
Wait, you can't even spectate people!
That's messed up.
Is that why they gave us their... Is that why they made us give the bar stream key to them?
So they could extend our stream?
Wait, you gave your stream key?
Did you also give their credit card number too?
So they can charge...
Oh, I think I didn't do that.
Wait, you guys didn't give them your credit card number too in the last three digits on the back?
I have to go do something really quick.
I'm sure that'll be alright.
Yeah, that's probably sure.
What are you gonna do?
We're streamers.
We're broke already.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're not even gonna get money if we get eliminated in the first four days.
So, what is the first event?
We're doing this for exposure.
Yeah, exposure.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, that's how they're paying us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you guys know the first event?
Like, what the details are?
Why don't we understand?
Is it really just a red light, green light?
Is it red light, green light?
I didn't really understand the rules.
It was like, there's boxes that you can hit to get benefits and stuff.
It's like Mario Kart.
Yeah, it's like Mario Kart, red light, green light.
Like, do you die if you move when the light's off?
Because it didn't say that.
Oh my god, what if it's a crab game?
I'm pretty sure this is basically a crab game, but spooky.
Because did you see in the rules?
They were like, you gotta be immersed as if you're actually in a haunted house.
And you gotta roleplay and stuff.
It's like GTA RP.
But in Minecraft.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I think it's like Crab Game S where you can probably just punch someone to make them move.
And then...
Oh, that's true.
But we're allies, right guys?
Yeah, we're allies.
Guys, right?
We're not gonna punch each other, right?
Yeah, no, we're all friends.
Yeah.
We're all good.
If you punch Gumi and I, you're punching babies.
Because we just installed Minecraft today.
Wouldn't wanna do that.
Yeah, you're a baby puncher.
She barely plays Minecraft.
Yeah, I don't even have my own skin.
I'm a bear.
That's when you know I'm a baby.
Oh, hello.
Hello?
Friends?
Yeah.
Can you guys hear me?
Oh, no, we can hear you.
It's just the quality is very terrible because there's a lot of people on the server.
Okay, thank god.
So the more people are eliminated, the better the bandwidth.
Hey guys, how's the volume by the way?
Oh, did you guys see the animatronics?
Oh yeah, the FNAF at home.
That's so cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, chat.
Look, look, look, chat.
One of them looked...
That one's gone.
There's FNAF at home.
Which FNAF?
Huh?
What the heck is...
Your mic...
Your voice chat is so messed up.
We can't hear anything.
It's like...
Oh, that sounds good.
Oh yeah,
look at this server though, guys.
It's actually crazy.
Let's see.
I've never played one of these games.
I'm gonna make sure sound guy is just double checking stuff for me.
Oh my gosh, I love your skin.
Oh my gosh, I'm a bear farmer!
Hello!
Yeah, I'm a bear farmer!
I'm here to farm.
I love it, I love it.
I'm new to Minecraft, this is my first day.
I just installed it today.
Yeah, she just installed it.
She doesn't even know how to crouch.
Yeah, I don't even have my own skin.
That's when you know you should not... you should like let me get through the first round.
As like a make a wish.
This is my make a wish to get through the first round.
Oh, it's Doki!
Yeah?
His name is Toppo.
Hello!
Hi Kame!
Hi guys!
Hello Doc!
It's me, Doc.
We need to win.
I'm just... yeah, you can just call me Doc.
That's my name.
Alright, I'll call you Doc McStuffins.
That's wrong.
Yeah, that's right.
That is insane.
What do you mean?
Yeah, yeah, what's the copyright free version of this?
For legal reasons, what is the name of these guys?
For legal reasons, what are their names?
Um, we should name them right now.
Uh, this one... what's a good name for this one?
Oh my god.
Um... Ralph.
Oh heck yes.
Oh my god.
This is Ralph.
Five Nights at Ralph's?
Um... Poe.
What should the name be?
Poe.
Okay, I think now we're going through legal territory now.
Hahaha.
Now we're going back to maybe getting a cease and desist letter.
Okay, how about, um, Steve?
Oh my god, my favorite game.
Five Nights at Steve's.
Oh, Minecraft has Steve copyrighted.
Is that... come on, that's crazy.
No, maybe like Bartholomew.
Yeah.
Ooh, now you're cooking, Hannah.
That's actually a good name.
Yeah, what is it?
What if... yeah?
What if there's hide and seek in the next few days?
I've been looking around for good hiding spots.
Oh, is there actually hide and seek?
Wait, you're friends with the admin.
Ask her.
Ask her what the game...
No!
You're literally friends with the creators.
Ask them what the games are.
You're right.
Let me ask.
Just be like, hey, I'll never tell people what the games are.
But like, you know I'm not gonna make it to the next rounds, but I'm just curious.
What are the next couple of games?
Oh, I like that.
I like that.
Yeah, Doki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Send that DM right now.
Don't worry, I have your stream open so you can send it whenever.
So... because you...
Oh, look.
This is a pretty good hiding spot.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's actually insane.
I don't even know how I can get up there.
You can't see me at all.
Yeah, I can only see your name.
Wait, no, I don't even...
Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
Wait.
Do you not see me?
No, I don't.
Your name tag disappeared.
Hiding spot.
Yeah, your name tag disappeared.
Also, are we supposed to like reconvene somewhere?
What did they start the first game without?
I don't know.
That would be pretty embarrassing if we just got instantly eliminated.
Alright, I'm gonna double check the announcement.
Oh, apparently not...
Oh, let's see.
Not everybody's in the server yet.
Wait, what the heck?
They're late.
They're 12 minutes late.
Eliminate them.
How dare they?
Right now.
Wait, if we eliminate the 12 people, only 8 people have to be eliminated on the next one.
Because they're late.
Oh my god.
That means we get to go through the first round for free.
I think so too.
Wait, do you see me here?
Nope, I don't even know where you are.
Oh wait, I see you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How did you do that?
Slash TP.
Yeah, you can tell me.
I see you.
You don't need to see it.
And then you gotta run around and jump on that bush.
What the fuck?
The one I'm standing on.
I can barely see.
Okay.
I can't even see anything.
You got this.
Okay.
Yeah, stand right where you need to jump.
Am I standing in the right area?
You're doing a good job.
Wait, maybe I'm gonna up the brightness.
And then you run forward.
How do I up the brightness?
I'm just gonna try and up the brightness.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, I up the brightness.
I still can barely see, but that's okay.
Run forward, jump.
Okay.
You're hitting this wall.
You have to make it pass the wall and then turn in.
Oh no.
And apparently there's a parkour course later.
Oh, I made it!
Oh, almost.
You made it one under.
Oh.
Wait, are you above me?
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, look up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, why is this so dark?
Oh, no!
I give up.
I'll just die.
I'll die underneath you.
So they'll know that you're...
So they're like, oh, we got the person.
So they'll run away and then you'll be safe.
Oh my God.
And then I split the money with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you split $1,000, like $65.
$60, $40.
$60 for me.
$70,000.
$60, $40.
What?
I helped you get to the end.
If it wasn't for me, you'd be caught.
All I'm saying...
When are we going to go to Japan together?
And you promised to pay for part of it.
Oh, you did it!
You did it!
Wait, I did it, but I jumped away!
Okay.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
No!
You jumped.
I keep jumping past it.
But if we all...
But if we're both on the same hiding spot, wouldn't we both die at the same time?
No, because look...
It's like...
Okay, get up here.
Get up.
I'm here.
They can't see me.
They can't...
Make the jump.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can see you very clearly.
They can't see me.
No!
I keep fucking...
Okay.
I can't make the jump.
Hold your crouch button.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Pro Minecraft trap.
We did it.
Jump up here.
And then you stay in that corner.
I'll stay in the other corner.
Okay.
Because I can't see you.
Yeah, yeah.
You don't know where I am.
I can't see anything either.
Girl, you just walked into me.
But I can't see anything.
And then if you hold crouch, you hide your name tag.
Oh, wait.
That's so smart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my God.
We're going to win this.
We're going to so win that $70,000.
$60,000.
$70,000 in $70,000.
$70,000.
All right.
So, guys.
All right, guys.
So, this is a custom Minecraft horror map.
They actually made an entire installation for this.
There was a whole folder.
Oh my God.
Who wants to put them out right now?
Yeah, call them out on stream.
Yeah, I called him out on stream.
I called him about on stream.
Yeah.
I let him call.
It's like a world pack and you just download the file.
And then like... wait, is that Mickey Mouse?
Oh my god, Mickey's in the server.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they got Mickey.
Yeah, so like basically we're not even using the Minecraft launcher.
We're using a custom launcher for this.
So like all your texture packs, resource packs don't even show up for this one.
So like when you install it, everything is already there.
Are you gonna make tacos?
Okay, I'll talk to my chat then.
Can you talk to my chat too?
Okay.
Okay, I'll talk to your chat as well.
Okay, don't worry, I'll entertain your chat as well.
Are you gone yet?
Okay.
Oh.
Are you still here?
Yeah, tell a story that I would tell your chat.
Okay, okay.
When you're gone.
Let me know when you're gone.
I'm gone.
Okay.
Are you still here?
Okay, alright.
So people in Gumi's chat, come to my...
I stream on YouTube.
You son of a bitch.
I knew you would do this.
I didn't leave because I knew it.
Well, I knew you didn't leave so I was testing you.
I was testing you to see if you're still here or not.
I knew you didn't leave.
I'm not even gonna tell you when I leave.
Just keep talking.
Okay.
Anyway, guys.
Anyway, so I was talking to my chat about this map because I don't know if Gumi's here.
I don't know if Gumi introduced it.
But basically, this is a Twitch Rivals Minecraft.
Oh, hi.
I came from Gumi's chat.
Oh, hey.
Hey.
Anyway, so this is basically full... everything in here was like custom made just for this event.
So there's like 150 participants.
And it's basically like Squid Game but what if it's spooky?
So it's like a haunted mansion.
It's so funny because in the rules, they were like, please roll.
Play and immerse your viewers and immerse all the other participants as if you're really trapped in the haunted house.
And I was like reading that.
I was like, what the fuck?
So, but it's actually crazy though.
The amount of detail and the amount of like the amount of like effort they put into this entire world because everything is custom here.
Like you see the resource packs, the like the voice chat and everything.
And like almost everything.
Everything in here was just like Squid Game.
But like what if it's a haunted mansion type deal?
And apparently there's going to be two games.
It's going to last like six days or something.
But each day people get eliminated.
And apparently the first game is some red light green light thing.
I read the rules for the first two games because every day is like two games.
And I got so confused because I didn't even realize it was supposed to be red light green light.
I was like looking at it.
I'm like, this is red light green light.
But maybe I'm illiterate.
Anyway, so I think like the first game 20 people gets eliminated.
And then I don't know what happens the second game because I'm going to see if I can survive the first game.
And yeah, they're like you can have allies and everything.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently the rules was like you should not be swearing.
But like I guess like you could swear on your own stream.
But like not like during voice chat.
I assume.
But like I'm already talking in voice chat.
So like, oh, this is going to be an issue.
But they're like no profanity.
So like, yeah, I'm pretty sure I broke the rules already.
When it comes to profanity.
But there's like 150 people here.
Only top 20 wins money.
But don't worry.
We're just doing this for exposure.
I know there's like lots of Minecraft players on here.
Because there's a Minecraft event.
So like, yeah, we're not going to be making it to top 20.
Because Minecraft players are at a whole other level.
They've been doing like these Minecraft like the...
And what was it called?
The Minecraft championship.
The MCC shit like that.
They've been doing this on the daily.
So...
If we make it past day one, that's a win on my book.
Anyway, it's fun though.
I got me lots of Goomy's friends.
And talking to a lot of people.
But yeah, Minecraft players are at a whole other level when it comes to minigames.
So like, it'd be nice to just survive the first day.
I hope Goomy's chat was entertaining.
Got like exposition for this tournament.
But yeah, anyway.
If I don't live past day one.
Then it's rest week for me.
Yay!
I get to...
It's a win-win!
If I make it past day one.
Wow!
I beat some Minecraft players on day one.
If I don't make it past day one.
Yay!
I get a vacation.
So...
So it's a win-win honestly.
But yeah, a lot of...
Yeah.
I mean they got a hundred and...
I mean they got a hundred and fifty streamers.
That is an accomplishment on its own.
Because they managed to get a hundred and fifty streamers.
To coordinate their schedules for this one event.
And that's like...
It's very difficult to get like thirty.
I had a rough time.
Coordinating the schedule for like thirty people.
So think about a hundred and fifty in one place.
Yeah.
It's actually crazy though.
It's crazy.
It's Minecraft.
Not like they had...
I'm DUCK!
I mean they'll be playing Minecraft anyway.
But yeah.
It's basically like a merge of like different streamers.
From different communities.
There's like Spanish streamers too.
Because there's the server.
The Discord server.
Was...
Has like instructions in both Spanish and English.
Because like I know like Minecraft is really, really popular.
Yeah I was so surprised i didn't realize Minecraft.
I guess like quackity it would make sense because quackity is like one of their biggest streamers on twitch um but yeah minecraft is like incredibly popular um uh for spanish speaker viewers Viewers...
Are you back yet?
Did you make your taco?
Okay guys, anyway, on Gumi's chat...
For those who don't know me, I'm DokiBird.
You can find me on Twitch right now if you really want to have some streamer interactions.
I mean, she's not... how is she gonna know?
I'm surprised we haven't started yet.
What are we still waiting on?
Also, have you guys heard about Twitch Prime, Gumi's chat?
So Twitch Prime is basically...
You can subscribe to your favorite Twitch streamer for free for one month.
If you have Twitch Prime.
So click that button.
Okay, before you click that button, go to the search bar.
Type out DokiBird.
It's only exclusive to like DokiBird channel too, by the way.
Because I have a special deal right now.
Hey, hey Gumi!
You're back!
And Gumi's channel too.
You can also Twitch Prime.
Yeah, it's exclusive on Gumi's channel and my channel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the Twitch Prime stuff.
Yeah, yeah, you came at just the right time.
I was talking about our Twitch Prime sponsor.
You have to remember I have...
I have wireless headphones.
I was listening to Tidehunt.
Yeah, yeah, so you heard me like chill us, right?
Like both of us.
Yeah, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was talking... I was hyping you up, Gumi.
Yeah, because that's my wife right there.
Yeah, I gave like explanation.
I don't know if you like explain the server stuff.
I don't know.
Honestly, I'm just saying ball.
Like, budget we bought.
Fuck it.
Whoa!
Wait, did you see the rule where we're supposed to put it on email only mode when we start the game?
Yeah.
Are you gonna do that?
I already did it, man.
Oh, that's why they're in my chat talk.
That makes sense.
I didn't do it.
So yeah, for those who don't know, we're supposed to put our chats at emote only mode to prevent people from cheating and ghosting and stuff.
But like they said, we can do it when the game starts.
The game hasn't started yet.
That's the thing.
So yeah, my mods.
The moment the first round starts.
Please put it at emote only mode.
I'm not gonna forget.
It's so freaking good.
Are you eating your taco?
Yeah, I'll give you a taco.
Whoa!
In front of everybody?
It's a pretty inside a taco.
What?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Should we go explore a little bit more?
Hey, there's Link.
You want me to sit on taco?
You have one.
You have two hands.
One hand can eat the taco.
Okay, then I'm gonna go push a taco then.
Yeah, take voice activation.
Let them hear your voice.
What?
I'm on voice activation.
Let's go.
All right, let's go.
Wait, I should do voice activation too.
Let me...
Wait, how do I do this?
Press to disable...
Press to start recording.
How do I...
How do I do act...
Oh, there it is.
All right.
She's eating a taco.
Wait, Doki, look!
Mickey Mouse is my friend!
Oh my God, it's Mickey Mouse!
You got invited?
It's me, Mickey Mouse.
Oh my...
What the hell?
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait...
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
This event is sponsored by Disney?
Okay.
I'm so...
Unmute yourself.
Oh shit.
Am I unmuted?
Am I good?
Can you hear me?
Oh no.
No!
How do I...
Oh wait, it's okay.
Okay, I can hear.
Yeah.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Oh my God, it's so cool.
I can't believe it.
Disney sponsored Minecraft.
Yeah, they did.
Some people have an aura.
That's crazy.
It's not that that's bad, you know.
No, the hand was just like...
Mom!
It felt...
She's eating a taco right now.
Mm-hmm.
I just made a carton shot of tacos.
Oh shit!
Whoa!
Tacos are so sweet!
I mean, oh my God!
Oh my God!
I'm sorry for putting a Lord in the house.
I'm just gonna use his name in vain.
Uncle Baby Billy!
Can you guys still hear me?
Yeah, we can hear ya.
There's a cutscene?
Oh my God!
1984.
Oh My God!
The fight!
The fit of 1984!
The fight of 1984!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back to...
That's how I play Balor!
How do we skip this cutscene?
We don't need lore?
Oh my god.
This is so elaborate!
It's okay, the round hasn't started yet, guys!
We're fine!
The moment the round started, then we do it.
Who are these people?
The thing is, I don't know if these guys can hear me when I'm talking right now.
Because I have push... okay, I don't think they can because no one said anything.
To me.
No one said like, shut the heck up.
I just assumed nobody could hear me.
So I had to pause and be like, okay, wait, I can't swear.
I could probably say something.
No, I'm on voice activation because I got lazy.
Oh my god, chicken!
Maplewood Town, September 13th.
I have no idea what is going on!
Like, where did the haunted house come in?
Like, when does that come into play?
Oh, is that the house?
Oh no, that's the house!
Yeah, I know, but I'm just like, thinking...
Oh my god, this is like a debut stream.
The lore video that's like 15-20 minutes long.
We're watching a VTuber debut now.
Oh, we're like news reporters!
They sent in like 150 new...
What the heck?
What is...
They sent in 150 news reporters to get in the...
To figure out what's going on in the haunted house.
We need every angle.
Yeah, we sent in 150.
One of them will go viral.
Even like five news cards...
Wait, is it like one person per card?
Okay, now that's excessive.
Each news reporter brought in their own card.
Who cares about global warming?
They don't know about card pooling.
The CO2 emissions go crazy.
Oh, what the heck?
There's ghosts?
Oh my god, it's so spooky!
Why are you here?
I'm here to report the news.
I'm here to represent BBC News.
Oh, there's 46... Oh, sweet!
Four people already got eliminated.
I mean, sucks for them, but...
Did you see that?
Four people already got eliminated!
I don't have permission to speak?
Yeah, you guys are in my mind.
I don't have permission to speak.
Silence, Tokyo.
No!
They actually silenced us!
Oh, we can talk now!
I can hear you guys!
Oh my god!
I thought they silenced us!
They just trauma-dumped on us.
Yeah.
So, are we like news reporters here?
150 news reporters?
I think so.
I think we're the TV people.
Oh my god.
It's like that movie.
You guys wanna see this hiding spot I found?
Oh, wait.
If you're the seeking...
Oh my god, it's like that Will Ferrell movie where they send in all the news reporters to fight.
It's just like that Will Ferrell movie.
It's so dark up here.
Yeah, yeah.
If there's hide and seek, Gumi found the perfect spot.
They can't see us for fair.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh no!
I didn't have emote's only mode!
Where are my mods?
Can I
look at this?
Oh yeah, sure.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Okay, but I'm like a baby though, so...
Wait, can I get promoted to wife number two if I play Valorant with you?
You'll get promoted to my one and only...
Okay, absolutely then.
Okay, wait.
I need to put mod only mode.
How do I put mod only mode?
Guys, I don't know how to do it.
Guys!
Wait, wait.
Emote.
Okay, I'm gonna message.
Can you help me put on emote only mode on my stream?
Sorry.
Caps.
It's okay.
I personally messaged a mod to show up.
Because I'm still... I'm a bit lazy.
Yeah, see?
You get some good hard spots.
Yeah, but what if you don't make it to the round to do this?
Well, you got to put it on my list.
Oh yeah.
Boob Bears, if you got to the finals, you got to split 60-40.
Well, it's gonna be 60-20-20.
Oh, true.
60-20-20.
So I get 60 and you two get 20.
Got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, so like if FruBarris win first place...
And because we showed him the god spot...
Um...
Yeah, that seems fair.
Yeah.
I'll give away all my money.
I think that's pretty fair.
You have Minecraft money.
You don't need $70,000.
You have Minecraft money?
This guy got Minecraft money.
Yeah, you got Minecraft money.
I bet $70,000 to you is like an apple.
It's a lot.
It's not.
It's a lot of an apple.
Guys.
I don't know about that.
Dude, I just finished my two tacos.
It was so freaking good.
Ooh.
Yumbo.
What?
I guess...
It was Chinese Soda Tacos with salsa verde and...
Ooh.
Ooh, that sounds so good.
What a goodness questions.
I'm so delicious.
So like...
It's elevating.
Are we...
After two minutes and 30 seconds, do we get like TP to the first game?
We die.
Okay, because I'm going to be like...
It'll be a bit awkward if like we're supposed to head to the place or something.
Maybe.
Because we're like, you have two minutes...
No, everybody's gone.
That's the spooky part.
Uh-oh.
Everybody's missing.
I don't know.
People are gone.
Oh.
People are disconnected.
A lot of people disconnected to fix their voice.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, no.
There's people up front.
Okay.
Nice.
Six people already got eliminated.
So like...
Before the games even started.
So we have a chance.
Yippee.
Yay.
I feel like we should have the...
Inside.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We didn't get to explore inside.
We only went to like one room.
I'm actually like lost.
We only had to explore one room and that was it.
Yeah.
We got to explore.
That's not coffee.
Buddy passback.
Nice, Emu.
What do you say hi to?
Oh, my god.
There's a skull.
There's a couple of friends over there too.
Yeah.
I'm kind of scared.
What if we go in this room and our voices start laughing out again.
Oh, my god.
No, it's already starting.
Oh, shit.
There's so many of you.
You're going to go find me.
Doki run!
Quick!
We gotta get our bandwidth back, Gumi!
Bye!
We gotta get our bandwidth!
No, man.
It's Gumi.
Get that through your head.
Doki and Gumi.
Call me Doki.
Yeah!
Look, it's two bears!
Oh my god, bears unite!
I'm a bear farmer.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, what did I just watch?
Do you farm bears?
Yeah, I farm bears.
I farm you.
Alright,
let's head over.
We gotta get our bandwidth back.
Alright guys, I still...
I still don't have... I have zero mods on my... It's an anarchy right now in my chat.
What?
None of the mods are online today for me.
That's crazy.
It's not looking so...
Oh no!
Doki!
Okay.
We got...
We're together!
Hold up my hand!
Gumi!
Oh no.
I'm scared.
There's so many people!
Oh my god!
There's so many people.
Okay.
Where?
There's too many people.
I can't!
I can't tap out to Toshimono-only mode!
Where's my mod?
Where is it?
I don't see the names here!
I'm trying to find Goofy!
I think I have time to start email only mode here.
If I tab out, I think I have time.
Okay, what was it?
There we go.
No!
I can't!
Because I'm
not on this mod!
No!
Where are my mods?
Oh no!
Wait.
The time started.
Oh no.
I can't!
None of my mods are on!
Oh no, it started!
What?
Oh wait, everything is quiet now.
Oh thank god.
But where's Goofy?
Where's Goofy?
She was going to put me on her backpack!
Oh!
My mod is on!
I don't know where my mod was that put it on, but thank you!
We did it!
Oh my god, another bear!
Oh my god!
Bears unite!
Where is she?
Friends.
Where's- Oh wait, it's like 4 minutes until we start?
I assume so, right?
I assume it's like 4 minutes until we start.
I hope so.
Oh like, did they- Did the voice chat just get dc'd for everybody?
I think it did.
I think they shut down the voice chat for everybody!
Nobody's talking.
Oh my god.
I see a lot of disconnected right now.
Can't have you guys tell me what's actually going on.
This is emote only.
I can't believe it.
Where people are.
Where people at?
There's so many Minecraft skins.
There's no way 150 people are right here.
Right now.
That's a lot of people.
Oh my god.
There's so many actual Minecraft players.
Because they have the creeper cape.
Right?
The cape means that you are an OG player.
I actually don't know.
I don't know much about the Minecraft lore.
Wait.
You guys can't even fact check me because you're all on emote mode.
You guys can't...
I can't even get fact checked.
Because you're all on emote mode.
No!
That means I can say the most ridiculous things and nobody can stop me.
Nobody can be like I'm actually me.
Oh my god.
How do I fucking...
How do I fucking banter when my entire chat is just emojis?
Like it's talking to a kindergartner.
Still trying to find people.
Wait.
It just went back to five minutes.
It reset.
It reset itself.
I'm so confused.
I'm so...
I can't be like...
Hey guys.
Are people hearing anything?
On like the other streams?
Or did everybody else's voice chat also crashed?
Or like doesn't work anymore?
I can't say...
I can't ask you guys.
But...
Start where...
Countdown will restart once disconnected.
Start where it left off.
Oh!
So am I supposed to reconnect?
Because the voice chat is off?
Oh maybe like...
Oh maybe like it crashed itself.
Okay.
So do I have to reconnect?
I'm scared of reconnecting.
I guess I can reconnect right?
I don't know.
I DON'T KNOW!
BECAUSE YOU GUYS CAN'T TALK TO ME!
I DON'T KNOW IF I SHOULD RECONNECT!
Yay or nay?
Do I reconnect?
Yay for...
Log out?
Reconnect?
Nay for like...
Don't reconnect.
Guys.
I mean... Yay or nay guys?
I DON'T KNOW!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON!
Okay.
Please do not dis...
Oh!
Okay nevermind!
Admin stopped me!
Nevermind!
Okay.
JK I don't need your help.
The admin stopped me.
Before I could do anything.
Thank god.
I was about to...
I was about to do it.
There's just so many skins here.
I didn't realize there were a lot of bears.
There's actually a lot of like big Minecraft players.
Isn't Tubbo like a really famous Minecraft streamer?
Oh and...
I was just like...
Look at this guy.
I'm like trying to find...
Trying to find...
Oh he is!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it.
I'm a true Minecraft player now.
Wait is that Elmo in a fucking bikini?
But we can't say fuck!
Wait that's Elmo in a bikini.
But we can't swear.
Like I've been trying to find...
Kumi this entire time.
And I can't.
I found so many other people.
Oh there's Rosita.
Doodle.
I know her.
She's a Vtuber.
Let's see.
I'm just slowly moving through the queue.
Moving through the queue right now.
To see if I can find her.
Like I mean six people have already been eliminated.
So...
Wait no eight people.
Eight people have already been eliminated.
So like at best like...
As long as I'm not like...
The 15th...
As long as I'm not like as bad as like 15 other players.
I should win this.
Why are there people in this corner?
Like that's really it.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I found her.
I did it guys.
We did it.
We found each other.
Now she can carry me.
I'm gonna use her...
I'm gonna use her friendship with all the other Minecraft players.
To make sure I don't die as well.
And I'm just the trophy wife.
I'm the trophy wife.
Yeah.
Gumi will save me.
Cause all the other Minecraft players would be like...
Oh my god.
Gumi you're a friend.
So we won't kill you.
And then they'll see me next to Gumi.
And they'll be like...
Oh my god you're Gumi's wife.
We won't kill you.
And I'm like oh thank god.
Thank god.
Protection by association.
I'm gonna get protection here.
Alright.
Yay.
Should we be at the starting line?
Come on Gumi.
Gumi come on.
Gumi.
Come on.
There's 40 seconds left.
They're gonna have a head start Gumi.
Oh no.
Come on Gumi.
I need the bodyguide protection.
Come on.
What are you doing just standing there?
I don't know if they're gonna TPS or not.
Oh no.
I don't know if they'll TPS.
I don't know if I should find her again.
What if I need to find her again?
Oh like what's the word?
It's so creepy when there's literally no sound.
You know?
There's like no sound at all.
And it's so fucking creepy.
Oh it's another cutscene.
Let's fucking go.
We are news reporters.
That's it.
You should now understand that the legend is true.
150 news reporters.
And now it is you that will be tested.
Representing BBC News.
Our wicked conjurer has put forth a series of challenging nightmares.
Each of which has spelled the end for a certain number of you.
No I should be PBS Kids.
Should you fail.
Representing PBS Kids.
Your soul will remain in the house of nightmares forever.
Look kids need to have news reporters as well.
And your life depends on your ability to succeed in them.
Lights out.
The first nightmare is called lights out.
To survive you must traverse a long path to the safe zone.
As you progress the lights will turn off and on randomly.
When the lights turn off the spirits can see you moving.
So you must stay complete.
That's why you have to stay still.
You can resume movement once the lights come on.
And come back on.
That's spooky.
You can find ability boxes scattered around the environment.
What do the boxes look like?
Purple ability boxes will give you an advantage over other players.
The abilities could be a three second speed boost potion.
Oh it is like Mario Kart.
Or a snowball that can freeze an opponent you hit for three seconds.
It is basically like Mario Kart.
If you move while the lights are out.
You will find yourself haunted by the spirits.
And momentarily unable to move.
At least you don't die.
A timer will count down until you can move again.
This is a race to the safe zone.
Only 140 of you will pass.
This means that 10 of you will meet your final ending here today.
Oh wait!
That means two people will get eliminated!
Oh okay now.
I don't want to jinx myself.
But like if I can get out of here.
If I am one of the two people that get eliminated.
I am just never playing Minecraft again.
If I am literally one of the two people that get eliminated.
I will be so fucking sad.
There is 142 people.
And I will be so depressed.
If I get eliminated.
I will be so fucking sad.
Please don't let me be the two.
Don't let me be one of the two.
That's all I want.
I will actually uninstall this game.
I became one of them.
Oh my god.
Okay.
30 seconds.
Oh my god.
They know.
They enabled voice chat again.
And then they disabled voice chat.
I like how they enabled voice chat.
Guys!
Okay.
Okay I don't like that.
I don't like that.
They should have not enabled voice chat there.
When we are all pipes down together.
Okay.
Oh my.
I can barely see the fucking light.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can't see the fucking light!
This is terrifying.
Follow the crowd!
They will leave me.
See you later nerds.
I do hear Fulham.
See you later.
I won't be there.
Fulham I love you.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
Slowly passing by the people that got knocked out.
Get fucked.
Oh.
Okay.
No.
Don't talk please.
I'm already overwhelmed.
Don't talk guys.
Don't talk.
Oh.
This is so scary.
Oh my god.
Please.
I can't see anything.
Move away from me.
I can barely.
Oh god.
Move.
I can't see anything.
I can barely see anything.
Oh my god.
I need to like get away from everybody.
I need to make sure I'm not bunched up with people.
No.
Because I really can't see anything.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Get fucked loser.
I mean get hacked loser.
Okay.
There's no way we can be the bottom two.
We didn't get frozen once guys.
There's no way.
There's... Oh.
No.
We're like almost in the front.
How are they faster?
I don't understand.
How are they so fast?
The people in the front.
Like I'm...
We're moving the same speed.
We're...
We're literally the same speed.
Is there like a bunny hop tech?
Guys I can't even ask you guys if you know what the bunny hop tech is.
What's the bunny hop?
What's the bunny hop tech?
These goddamn minecraft players.
These goddamn minecraft players and their bee hop tech.
Jesus Christ.
Oh there's a little short cut here.
Don't go that way.
What do you mean don't go that way?
Where do you go?
Where do you go though?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Follow the crowd!
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Oh my gosh.
Still surviving!
I'm just like the Minecraft players!
I'm just like them!
I'm going.
Oh my gosh.
I just left it up.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my gosh, guys.
Maybe I should be a Minecraft player.
Okay, here we go.
I almost thought I got hit.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, we passed by people.
We just passed.
Yeah, that's what you get for getting too cocky, man!
I can't see.
It's just names.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
So much.
I can't...
Wait.
I got blocked by 200 people.
I got blocked by 200 people there.
Oh, God.
Please, please.
Don't mic spam.
Please.
I beg of you.
I'm not gonna be good at this.
I can take control.
Oh, God.
Okay.
We're okay.
Hey, guys.
Just two seconds.
No, no, no.
What are you talking about?
Where is the safe zone?
How is it that far?
Fuck.
Okay.
There's still so much more that go.
I could barely, like, take in the surrounding.
Because it's just people.
All of them.
Oh, my God.
All I see are people.
Nice.
We're almost there.
Oh.
Please.
Please, don't.
Oh.
Nice.
I actually don't even know we're almost there.
I just feel like I've been running forever, chat.
I've been running for so long.
There's no way!
Nobody's at the safe zone, not even the front of the pack!
I think this is the first 50%.
Nobody's at the safe zone yet!
Please.
Please somebody hit the safe zone.
Please, I beg of you.
Somebody please!
So I know if the end is near!
That's all I want!
Is the end near yet?!
Oh my god.
Is there still people?!
Okay, I'm back.
Oh my god, there's still more!
How the hell is there still more?!
Alright.
Nice.
All I'm saying is I haven't been hit once yet.
I haven't been hit by the ghost yet, guys.
I'm practically gaming.
Get shit on.
Look at all these people sitting down.
Hehehehe.
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
That's the only thing I could hear.
Oh my god, they're so in the front.
Oh.
I don't understand how the moving thing actually hits though.
I feel like I should have been hit several times.
Oh god.
I like how nobody's getting the box.
Or like the box.
Only the front people can get the box right now.
So like I have not been hit once.
I have not hit the box once.
Lucky you.
We're in last place right now.
Where are we?
Okay.
We have to be in the middle of the pack.
Yes!
That's how it is!
Are you serious?
Oh, okay.
I'm too scared.
Too scared.
Oh my god.
Now I know why.
Now I know why they're in the front.
Yes!
I'm speeding now!
Okay, I'm speeding but yet she's still in the front.
Like what is this fucking bullshit?
I'm speeding yet I'm still not fasting.
Okay, I got snowballed.
Oh my god, I got snowballed.
Did I hit the box?
No, I missed!
Okay, okay.
It's all done now.
What is the freaking...
I'm so sorry.
How do you...
You slowed me.
I have a crunch against you.
It wasn't me.
It didn't do anything.
It flew like...
I slowed you.
Oh, I see.
I'm the one who gave that away.
I'm not in this.
Okay.
Okay, they hit it though.
It's where you are.
No.
Please.
Oh my god.
How is there still more?
You do it first.
Oh no.
Is there still more of this map?
I don't... I feel like I've been running for like 10 years.
I don't understand.
No one's at the safe zone.
We got this.
We can do this.
Don't let them know.
Oh, my god.
I got frozen.
Is this the safe zone?
No, it's not.
I need to be euthanized.
What the fuck?
Did you just hear that?
Someone said you need to be euthanized.
Oh, my god.
I'm shaking.
My freaking heart.
Oh, my god.
I'm shaking too, but it's because of the coffee.
What?
Just be euthanized.
A little bit of a f**k them.
Oh, I'm being so anxious.
I'm being so anxious.
I'm just trying to exist.
I'm not a gamer.
I have no idea.
I haven't been hit once.
There's no way.
You're in my face, HTC!
I have no idea.
I have no idea left or right.
I'm gonna go left.
Oh, gosh, Vic, where you going?
Okay, I'm going left.
I'm going left.
I trust left side.
Left side seems like they know what they're doing.
I trust the left.
That's a bad connotation, Fla.
Oh, please, guys.
Please, some of you turn into like bad connotations.
This is...
If it's not left, we're so fucked.
I don't even know what the fuck.
No, left or right.
I hate making decisions.
I want that.
Okay.
Wait, I didn't even get that?
Who the heck got it?
I'm scared.
I'm so sad.
I got pinged so hard.
Where is the server?
The server is not on West Coast.
I got pinged so hard.
I hit somebody!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
This is not fair.
This is a ping diff.
The ping diff is messing me over.
Goodbye.
Oh.
I messed up.
Please.
The moment I see people leading into the safe zone, I know the moment.
The moment I know it's almost over.
How are you?
It's still, it's still going.
This is a mile run.
It's literally the mile run.
It was out of panic.
Hi, Lexi.
We're still okay.
Lexi Murphy, what's happening?
Okay, not gonna lie, we should eliminate more than 10 people.
Guys, are we in the bottom 10, be honest?
This should have been like 20, at least 30 people.
Oh god, I thought that was a ghost.
That's just Tubbo.
Cuidado, Tubbo.
Okay.
Come on, come on, please.
No, that's not Tubbo.
Are we done yet?
We're just journalists.
We're not supposed to be running.
What the fuck?
How much more of this do we have to do?
Well, there's a box that's not for me, I guess.
Don't get near the person with the box.
Don't freeze me, don't freeze me, I'm just a girl.
Alright.
There's no way.
We must be top this time.
I didn't get stopped once.
Come on, bro.
We can do this, we can do this, we can do this, we can do this.
I'm dead, I'm dying.
I feel like, I feel like I've seen this place like 20 times.
I'm actually gonna poop my pants.
I feel like I've looked at the same hallway.
What a right combo.
No, not me, wait for me.
Don't freeze me.
It's in your pants.
What's up, bitch?
Hey, Flex.
Someone, please, chop this mansion in half, please.
Do we want to like, all the way in the front?
Yeah, that's crazy.
Dude, I think I'm gonna make it.
Chop this mansion in half for the love of God.
Flex, Flex.
There's so no one safe.
Get me, get me, you...
Okay, okay.
Get me.
But no.
That competition isn't between us.
No one is fucking safe!
What the heck?
If nobody in the front is safe, that means there's so much...
There's so much more!
There's so much more ahead of me!
We got this!
Are you okay?
Everything's fine.
I'm getting distracted by the English!
My foot is just...
Oh god.
This is it.
Please.
Somebody.
I got trapped, dude.
Hey Jack!
Your back's shaking!
You're gonna go crazy!
I'm actually gonna go crazy.
How come we're not done yet?
Bye bye.
Bye bye, Zerbiosh!
That's all I want!
Bye bye!
Leave me out!
No, no, no.
Be sure!
You got out.
Thank you for the false hope.
I appreciate it regardless.
Let me finish this race!
Wait, did I get haunted?
Was that hot?
Who's that?
No, that wasn't...
Oh my god.
Someone just fucking showed up in front of me.
I was like, who the fuck is that?
Fuck.
I'm just a girl!
I'm just a beautiful...
Okay.
Oh, nice, we're okay.
We're still okay.
I'm so far behind!
You're not far behind!
We haven't been stopped once!
There's no way we're behind!
There's no way we're one of the two that gets eliminated.
Guys, I didn't realize how big this mansion really is, guys.
Like, I'm already...
My energy is gone already.
I'm scared.
Or we could go for like a Hail Mary, throw it like...
Oh my god, there's a checkpoint?!
What the fuck does a checkpoint mean?!
Oh my god!
One of ten checkpoints.
Like, what do you mean checkpoint?
Oh, I don't know.
There's no fucking way.
He's doing more!
Oh shit, nice!
I can't believe it.
Why would you fall off?
It's a bridge!
How can you fall off from this?
Oh god, okay, now I'm scared.
Okay, now I'm scared a little bit.
Because I said that.
Alright.
I'm scared.
The moment I see one of 140, I know it's fucking over.
I'll be free.
The moment...
The moment I see one out of 140...
I know.
Freedom is so close.
Freedom will be there.
Oh my god, Vida, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
We're doing a Minecraft Witch Rivals, but I'm already so...
My mental is already...
I'm already so over.
I've been running this course, I feel like, for like 15 minutes straight right now.
We have to put out emo-only mode.
Because they're worried that people are gonna ghost.
Because there's 150 players.
And first prize is like $70,000.
So we have to have emo-only mode.
But right now...
Oh shit, nice!
Oh my god, fuck you.
You missed your shot!
He's in front of me!
How do you...
How do I miss something point blank...
Twice!
It landed!
There's no fucking way.
There's no fucking way I missed twice.
Okay.
Oh my god, nice.
Two out of 100 checkpoints.
Nice.
Two out of 100.
We're doing it, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Please.
Someone, please.
Take me out of this misery.
VAR!
Can we get some VAR on that?
Alright.
Here we go.
Yo, yo, yo, yo!
Where are we?
I wish there was a map!
Like, there's so many things in this Minecraft thing, but we don't have a map.
That's the only...
The only thing we're missing is a goddamn map!
So I know how far we have left.
That's all I want.
There should be players left.
Wouldn't it be funny?
I've been like, open mic this entire time.
There's no way.
I purposely made sure I was pushed to talk.
It would be so funny.
I've been like, annoying like, 140 people with me ranting about this game.
I thought I was about to.
There's no way.
Nobody could hear my cries of pain except for you guys.
Oh god.
We're so close.
I said that 10 minutes ago.
But we're so close, guys.
We're so close, guys.
I swear.
We're so close.
I got the speed.
But yet for some reason, she's still faster than me.
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's hope!
Guys!
Oh my god!
How far ahead is this man?
Bro, this guy is first place and nobody else has made it yet.
Oh my god.
There's hope!
We're so close!
I
like how everybody who's made it are just Minecraft players.
Guys, that 70k is going to a Minecraft player, guys.
70k is not going to a regular player like me.
We did it!
Oh my god.
We're so close.
We're almost there.
Oh!
It's going so fast!
Guys, I'm scared now.
It's going so fast.
it's going so fast, guys.
Guys!
Oh, god!
There's no way!
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared now.
Oh, wait!
It's right there, bro.
We got this.
Oh my god, is that it?
Oh my god.
I didn't realize how far back I was.
Oh, please.
We're so close.
Oh my god.
Please!
Oh!
I did it!
Oh, thank god!
I thought I was out of the start!
Oh, thank fucking god!
How?
I muted everybody!
Oh, thank god!
Please.
Oh, god.
Thank god.
Alright.
Un-emote mode, guys.
We did it.
Is my mod still around?
Un-emote mode.
How do I un-emote mode?
You can remove emote mode now.
How was I 97?
I thought I was doing pretty well.
I didn't get stopped at all.
How the fuck was I 97?
97!
I swear to... okay, at least guys, I don't have to uninstall this game.
I'm not one of the two people.
Oh... I'm not one... one of the two people that got eliminated.
Just so you guys know, two people will be eliminated in this game.
And I said I would never play Minecraft again if I was that unfortunate.
Oh my god.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy.
Jesus Christ.
I hope you guys could hear me with all the people talking.
I couldn't even tell you guys could hear me.
There was just too much dialogue.
Too many people were talking.
Oh my god.
I... like... oh no, I'm stuck.
I was like so overwhelmed.
I came in here...
Lots of energy... lots of energy prepared for this event.
150 people started talking and now I'm out.
All that energy gone.
Oh my god.
Alright, who's gonna be eliminated anyway?
I wonder who's gonna make it.
The batter... yeah, Gumi apparently made it.
I saw someone said in chat.
She made it.
I don't see her though.
I turned off the voice chat because it was just too much.
Like 150 people in this room.
Gumi was top 20!
Okay, she's a Minecraft player though.
She actually plays Minecraft.
Like I'm not surprised.
My best bet is I don't... cause the next game...
The next game is... is... PvP.
It's a 1v1.
And like I'm so fucked if like I'm against an actual Minecraft player.
It's like some goddamn PvP shit.
Alright guys, also like I stopped caring about the swear rule.
Like they're not gonna check this bot, right?
As long as I'm not swearing in other people's streams.
Like...
Guys, we all know I'm not gonna make it to fucking top 20.
Guys, I'm here for the content.
Yeah, 150 people and I'm the only one swearing.
Like I call that bullshit.
Like I believe the Minecraft players wouldn't...
The Minecraft players will follow the rules.
Like will follow the rules.
But the non Minecraft players like me would definitely not be following.
Oh wait, one more person.
Oh, okay.
Yay, we did it!
140 players!
Oh.
No, Tiffany.
Whoever you are.
No, Leifason.
I don't know who you are.
No, Sofitty.
Rest in peace.
I don't know who you are.
But...
Oh no, wait, that's a VTuber!
Oh no!
Project...
Oh, is that Project Melody?
No!
Melody!
Oh no!
Don't worry.
I'll carry on the banner.
The VTuber banner.
Rosadoodle.
I think Rosadoodle is still in too.
Don't worry.
We'll get eliminated the next game instead.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Now I can...
I should be able to...
Blink in.
I have to wait.
Oh my god, we woke up.
I just woke up from my nightmare.
Look at how fun.
People I know.
You're top five on the Minecraft category.
Oh god.
Please, I don't...
Don't have zero expectations.
Please.
Please have zero expectations on me.
I'm not...
I'm not like your other Minecraft players.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I was 97th in the race, guys.
Oh no.
No, then these children are watching!
No!
All right, kids.
If you're watching me and you have Twitch Prime, don't worry.
Your mom will have Twitch Prime.
How did y'all go so fast?
Oh no.
I'm so sorry.
Oh no, I can't believe it.
The Minecraft kids are watching me now.
Minecraft children, let me introduce you to better games.
All right, for all those who are new here, I actually usually stream on YouTube, but because this is a Twitch Rivals tournament, that's why I'm the Twitch.
But yeah, please check me out on YouTube if you enjoy this content.
I barely could take a video.
I'm just gonna stay in this entire mansion, because all I did was just run.
You scratched my CD.
Oh, sorry.
What the fuck?
What the- what did I- okay.
Okay.
I don't know what's going on with that girl.
My goodness.
Oh, yes.
No, I didn't get a chance to like...
Shit.
Actually, take in the mansion builds.
Because I swear I was just like...
I swear I was just like...
in the...
People were just like...
in my space.
I couldn't even see what was going on.
Espana?
Yeah, there's like a lot of Spanish speaking streamers in this tournament too.
Because Minecraft is really popular.
Oh wait, that's her again.
Every time I bump into her, she's eating.
Oh yeah, no, I was frozen and the lights were off.
I never got a chance to get haunted by the ghost.
I still can't believe it.
I never got haunted by a ghost.
But yet... what the f...
I never got haunted by the ghost.
But I was still 97.
Like, what is the tech?
What the heck is the tech?
I just...
God, you go so fast!
You run?
You run and hold space?
Oh, you don't manually jump?
You just let the jumping...
Wait, is that it?
You just... you hold space?
Oh, I've been manually jumping, by the way.
I've been...
I've been manually pressing the jump.
That's how you do it.
You do the bunny hop!
I...
Oh, um...
I've just been like... I've been doing this.
Oh, uh...
Yeah,
I didn't...
Well, now I know!
Now that I know, it's over.
It's over.
We're gonna be doing so well.
Okay, look.
People don't hold... hold buttons in FPS.
Okay, that's a lie, because we need a right click.
We hold the right click.
But, like, not for...
Not for jumping, okay?
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but in, like, shooter games, we don't jump a lot.
Because when you jump, you're more predictable.
So, like, I didn't know the tech.
Come on, come on.
Come on, give me some more.
Keep acting as if we've never been here.
Oh, my God.
You know when he said that OVO was, like, working for you?
At least, like, not a lot of people got eliminated, though.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, there's a little girl.
I just saw the mob of people, and I saw the mob of people go right.
And I was like, okay.
Uh-huh.
I felt like I was...
I wonder, like...
I wonder if, like, right was faster than left, though.
Leave it, leave it.
I wonder.
This is a long intermission.
I can slow this with my stop-nap as well.
Sit with the little girl.
This is a very long intermission.
Take us to the second game.
Wait, I have an egg.
It clearly shows that it was an accident.
There was...
I have an egg on my bottom right.
What is that?
Yeah, his eyes actually...
Oh, my God.
Where is Gumi?
He's right behind me.
Playing Apex Minecraft now.
I mean, there's Roblox Apex.
I don't know if you guys have ever seen it.
I played, like, Overwatch Roblox just because I was curious.
Guys, stream snipe for me.
Where is Gumi?
Wait, Doki!
Hello!
Would you want an alliance with me, Guapo, and E-Rob?
It's a winning team, I swear.
Are you sure?
What if we get eliminated?
How can we get eliminated?
We have E-Rob.
Oh, that...
Wait, but...
No, that's why we're gonna get eliminated.
Don't listen to her, E-Rob.
Don't listen to her.
What do you mean by that?
Don't listen to her, E-Rob.
It's okay.
He...
You know, he...
He didn't lose the last one.
He made it before the seven people that got eliminated.
Okay, what's the placement?
What did E-Rob place?
We don't have to talk about that.
E-Rob...
What did you place, E-Rob?
We don't have to talk about that.
As long as you qualify...
102.
102?
E -Rob?
Mendo, what did you place?
I was like ten behind you or like eight behind you or something, because I...
Yeah, I had a booty.
102 is not...
Are you sure?
Be nice.
So, are you joining us or nah?
Okay.
Sure.
I'll join your alliance.
Okay, so...
Do you know the next game?
Is like this.
We did some 1v1 shit, right?
Wait, Doki, what did you get?
Definitely not 102.
Okay, what did you get though?
Because I didn't see you up front.
I was top 100.
Just so you know.
Oh, but like, how top 100 were you?
Look, top 100 counts.
It's below EROP.
Okay, so double digits.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Double digits.
That's all you need.
It's a 2 view, not 3 view.
Okay.
So in a 1v1, do you beat EROP?
Be honest.
Yeah, I think so.
Do you even play Minecraft?
No, no, no.
Doki knows how to play Overwatch.
Doki is cracked.
Okay, Overwatch isn't Minecraft.
Yeah, but...
You don't even play Minecraft!
I've beaten the game on hardcore.
That's great, EROP.
That's good for you.
I'm proud of you, man.
That's so good.
Have you?
No, no.
Bro, Minecraft's been out for like 20 plus years.
You beat hardcore Minecraft.
Yeah, I beat Minecraft hardcore.
Like when I was like 13.
Oh, man.
Come on.
We're a team, guys.
We're a team.
That laugh is so toxic.
Hey, Steve with 8 out of 10 likes coming through.
Watch out.
8 out of 10?
It took you three years on stream to beat Minecraft hardcore?
No, it took me like two months.
You could not force that out of me.
I believe in this team.
This next game is about lying.
Oh.
Everyone's muted.
Maybe there's like eggs up here.
Alright.
Yeah.
We'll win, right guys?
No.
What's the 15 incident?
What my chat are asking?
Okay.
After rivals, you can ask that.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I believe.
I believe in this team.
Wait.
So what?
What is this?
What is the second game?
I didn't really understand it.
I think I'll tell us.
Yeah, we'll get a video that even EROB can understand.
Oh, okay.
Sweet.
Nice.
As long as he understands, our team will be solid.
Yes.
Did you read the rules though?
It's in the daily itinerary.
Yeah, I read the rules.
I just didn't really understand the game.
Yeah, I don't really understand.
Yeah, I was just like, what?
The lying thing?
I think you get one of the three.
So it's like rock, paper, scissors, but like, oh, I have rock.
And I have to like lie or betray.
Yeah, so it's just like Among Us or something.
So it'd be like I...
Yeah, it's kind of like playing Overwatch and only playing ball.
And then if you get counterpicked, you complain.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's your fault.
I paid $40 to only know it's free to play now.
I paid $40 for this Hammond skin.
I should be allowed to play Hammond.
Yeah.
All right, guys.
I believe in this team.
Guys.
Guapo already picked his though.
Guapo said he's Blade and he's refusing to swap.
So like, I don't know.
Yeah, I'm Blade, but there's only three.
So we have to check these two rooms.
I didn't see any.
Yeah.
Hi, Mendo.
You made it two.
I did.
Okay.
Do you want to guess what this game is?
What number did you get?
Because I know your chat is snitching on you.
I said top 100.
That's all that matters.
You weren't lying, I guess.
It is top 100.
I think it was pretty close.
What were you?
I got like 20 or 30 or something.
You can't say that.
You got 102.
Was that you at the finish line?
I was sitting there.
Yeah.
Okay.
Somebody was like, Sasha, you're going to make it.
All right.
That was me.
I was yelling for E-Rob, but he actually Yeah.
It's okay.
As long as we're below E-Rob, that's all that matters.
See, I was trying to grease people up front so I would have got like top 10.
I was getting all the snowballs and stuff.
I didn't get caught by the ghost at any point except for right in front of the finish line because I tried to get greedy.
Top 100 is top 100.
You can't take that from me.
I got caught like three times.
Dave, you made it.
Let's go.
I'm glad.
I'm scared of the next game.
Yeah, me too.
I'm shaking in my boots.
I don't want to lie.
And I didn't know how to jump too.
I think it's like rock, paper, scissors.
Wait, let's go look for E-Strike.
It's like rock, paper, scissors.
I think it's like rock, paper, scissors.
Hey guys, is Scooby playing fucking Pokemon right now?
It's not rock, paper, scissors.
What do you mean?
No!
That's everything I relied on the intel that's in the game.
It's like rock, paper, scissors, guys.
If it's not like rock, paper, scissors, then what do I do?
Is that one over here?
What do I do if it's not like rock, paper, scissors?
Oh, she's at the Freddy's?
Yeah, right over here.
I'm heading over.
Where was the eighth one?
What do you have?
Let's see all the different Minecraft skins.
Wait, this is not it.
Yo-Yo.
I feel like I wouldn't even understand the Easter eggs because I feel like it's going to be Minecraft related.
And I'd be like, what the fuck is that?
Sorry, the heck is that?
It's the orange guy.
Where is the finale?
Oh, it's over here.
I love looking at the...
She moved to the bedrooms?
Oh my god.
I just wanted to say hi.
I can't believe it.
I have to do like this merry-go-round.
The webcam.
Which bedroom?
There's like 20 bedrooms.
Which one's the right bedroom?
She's running down the...
Oh my god.
Where the heck is she?
Where is she?
I can't believe it.
Guys, look at me.
Can you tell I'm holding space jump now?
Look, I would have been way ahead if I knew about the space...
holding space tech.
If I knew the holding space tech, I would have been first place.
Easy.
I was literally nerfed and still got top 500, guys.
I...
I was nerfed so hard.
Wait, Gumi!
There's two.
Gumi!
I saw you made it.
I made it.
I was so scared.
I was like number 97.
But I was top 100.
I got 22nd.
I was surprised.
I didn't realize you're supposed to hold space bar.
I was manually jumped.
Do you know what?
I thought that.
I was like damn.
She probably doesn't know how to sprint jump.
Yeah.
I was like how are they so fast?
I'm doing the same thing as them.
And then people were like you're supposed to hold space bar when you're jumping.
It's great because I didn't get hit by the ghost too.
I never got hit by the ghost but I was so far behind.
I was so confused.
I did.
I got hit once.
Are you looking for the Easter egg, Skokie?
No, I'm just chilling.
I was looking for Menda and Erob earlier.
Oh really?
Yeah, because they wanted to do an alliance.
And stuff.
They're saying this one is like a rock, paper, scissors.
The next game.
And it's all about lying and stuff.
Yeah.
But what happens if you guys go against each other then, Wendoki?
Then like...
Then I guess the alliance is over.
What happens if we go against each other, Gumi?
Gumi?
60-40.
Like...
I'll give you 60 if you let me.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, you can take 40.
If you let me win, right?
Because that's how much you love me, right?
Yeah.
You wouldn't lie to me like that, right?
No, I wouldn't.
Do I look like a man to you?
Oh, that...
Shit.
Who hurt you?
You know who.
You know every single one of my exes.
You literally know every one of my exes.
You're okay.
What do you mean who hurt me?
You know 1x, 2x, 3x, 4x.
Red fish, blue fish, and purple.
There is no eggs, Miya.
They're the TV's.
Oh, is that what the eggs are at the bottom, right?
Hey, anyone seen an egg ever?
Wait, but what do we get if we get all the eggs?
They're the TV's.
They're the televisions.
Oh.
But what do we get if we get the Easter eggs?
Do we get like a thousand dollars?
We get a thousand dollars.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, Toki, come here.
Here, let's do this real quick.
Yes, V.
I don't know, I'm on the other end as well.
Fine, but clutchable, clutchable?
V, and then settings, and then turn 3D voice to reduced.
Oh, 3D audio?
Yeah, 3D audio to reduced.
Oh, oh shit.
That might help a bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Minda, what do we do?
Oh, wait, emo only chat, emo only chat.
I got some of the Easter eggs.
How many?
There's three in this corridor.
I got seven.
There's one on the outside.
I'm nine.
Where, can you take me there?
So how is this alliance gonna work?
There's only seven seconds left.
Alright, good luck everybody.
Good luck.
I'm blinking.
I'm blinking too.
Oh no.
Emo only, emo only, emo only.
Oh, it's like a carnival.
Oh my god, it's Disneyland!
This is why Mickey's here!
It's a carnival?
This is exactly why Mickey was here.
Whoopie.
It's like an amusement park.
I don't know.
Wait, yo, yo, yo, BTMC.
Yo, Sapna, we're gonna do something.
I saw E-Rob.
Yo, how did you do it?
You got this bro.
Best of luck.
I'm scared guys.
I'm so scared.
I don't understand this game at all.
I don't understand this game.
I have to take a picture.
Honestly, we're doing...
It's because we're doing team with the gringos.
Who the fuck?
It's not as overwhelming as the first game.
That's for sure.
Oh my god, it's Elmo in a bikini!
Where's Elmo?
In a bikini.
Can I get a diamond formation?
Where's my squad at bro?
Yeah, where's my alliance?
Where the heck is my alliance?
I give you a high five at TwitchCon.
So...
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to survive without my allies?
Rock, paper, scissors.
How would I survive?
It will play five games.
Four rounds each.
One versus one.
No!
Oh my god, that's so loud.
That's so loud.
I've never seen somebody so sad about rock, paper, scissors.
Holy fuck.
The guy was full on despair.
What did rock, paper, scissors do to that man?
I don't know.
People are getting eliminated right now.
30?
I'm gonna be in that 30, guys.
There's like a 50-50.
There's like 80-30.
A 20 chance I'm in that 30.
Okay, what did you say?
As the non-Minecraft player, I'm so fucked.
The non-Minecraft player here.
I'm actually fucked, guys.
Why is the game volume loud?
Oh my god, the ambient voice.
It's so loud.
The music.
Where's my ally groups?
Where's my ally group?
There's so many other Minecrafters here.
But not the ones I wanna find.
Isn't that the fucking fighting game player?
Oh my god.
This is like the...
The crossover of the century.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna win.
But just know...
A Spanish streamer told me Argentina sucks.
ERO!
Oh my god, I was looking for you.
That's...
He's in the Spanish streamer game.
Where the fuck is he going?
Dude, he does.
Two more minutes, guys.
Two more minutes.
I need to go from 7 to 8 digits in my...
Why am I stressed out?
I know I'm not gonna make it.
I shouldn't be stressed out about this.
We all know I'm not gonna make it to the end.
We saw the top 20 in the fucking running course.
in the fucking running course.
Jesus Christ.
That should not be that loud.
I do not care about the ambience.
They're so perfect.
They're just...
Please give me my cutscene.
Wait, what's this?
Are these the balloons?
Oh, they're like balloons.
Whoever like...
The team that made this world...
It's actually insane though.
It's so...
It's so good.
Do you really want to be with...
I just love all the builds and everything.
The aesthetics and stuff of everything.
Like the world building.
It's actually insane.
Wait, there's more?
There's an outside?
The circus?
There's...
Oh my god.
There's an outside?
Does anyone know what his next game is?
I think it's like rock, paper, scissors.
But you get like one of the three.
Alright.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It's a deserted circus.
What the hell?
Where are the clowns at?
Where to kill the clowns?
Oh, wait.
You can't even get up here.
Scam.
Holy shit.
Bro, what is this?
A circus for giants?
Like, what the fuck?
This area is actually huge.
I'm scared.
Why do we need such a big arena for rock, paper, scissors?
I don't understand.
If it's rock, paper, scissors, then like why do we need such a big area?
A cage would work.
Just put us in a fucking cage.
Alright, off we go.
Off we go.
What's so embarrassing is, I actually played Rust, of course.
I didn't know that.
Oh my god.
I'm still like, oh!
Skull scroll blade.
Oh this skull, I assume is...
rock, paper, scissors.
It's funny that we have a copyright free version of rock, paper, scissors.
Congratulations to those who made it through Lights Out.
The next nightmare will be a more intimate affair.
Yeah!
Okay.
Why do I keep choosing skull?
Oh!
The fuck?
This is gaslighting!
Ha!
What the...
That's the tiebreaker?
Oh my god, those six... that's gonna be me.
That's so stressful!
Oh my god, guys.
It was a good run, guys.
I'm not a liar.
I can't believe it.
I can't lie, guys.
I'm not known as a liar.
Okay, I need a recap.
Oh my god.
This is gonna be so difficult.
I'm so bad at lying!
I can't believe it.
I'm such a... I'm a good person.
Being forced to lie and gaslight people.
I don't know what career is.
Why is this?
This is gonna be... locate them, walk, talk to others.
Oh, we have to find the circus.
We rip it.
Where the fuck was... oh, it was over here.
We gotta go to the circus.
The person to my left always tells a lie.
Alright, there you go.
We found the circus.
New Jersey.
Found it!
We found the circus.
Rigatoni with the Red Souls.
How do I...
I'm like trying to think how to fucking...
Linguini.
Mmm, yes.
Amazon.
They keep ordering their Uber Eats right now.
Farm of John.
Farmer John.
Why are they like, intruding on a date?
I'm just this third wheel just listening to their fucking pasta order.
I'm just like, what the hell?
I'm thinking...
I am!
You are!
Go me!
There you are!
There I am.
This game is gonna be so difficult.
Did you see my DM by the way?
Oh, you DMed me?
Yeah, I just saw them.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah!
I saw it.
Yeah, I saw them earlier too in the first round.
Monka- Monka!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
Don't get eliminated.
Protect me.
Don't worry.
I'll protect you!
Oh my God.
This game is gonna be so difficult.
Because, like, you have to like...
You have to lie and I don't... I'm not always tell the truth.
Shut up!
What do you mean?
Stop talking!
This is so difficult!
Wait, wait.
We're forming an alliance, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So like when you fight me, let me win because I'll lose... I'll get kicked out.
Well, it's whoever has less points.
Yeah, yeah, but you'll let me farm points off of you, right?
Hello!
Well, only if I have more points than you.
Yeah, yeah.
And you'll always have more points than me.
You're a Minecraft player.
Girl, this game ain't got nothing to do with Minecraft.
You're a Minecraft... Yeah, people... people trust you!
People don't...
That's true!
And people also trust me too, but like I'm just way too trustworthy.
Don't trust me.
You let me farm points off you, right?
You let me farm points off you.
I would vote.
Right?
If I get eliminated, who will bring the content?
I'm gonna be...
I have bad luck, but...
I only have good luck when... when it doesn't matter.
It's okay.
Alright, when you're up against me, just pick... just pick Blade, okay?
I'm just...
Every time, you pick Blade.
I... I'm gonna... I'm gonna pick... I'm gonna pick...
Yeah, yeah, pick Blade.
The biggest brain.
Wait, Gumi, what is it?
What is it, Gumi?
Oh, wait, she's AFK.
Never mind.
It's okay, guys.
We got this, guys.
Gumi will let me farm points off of her, so I won't be bottom six, guys.
Of 28 people.
There's no way.
I refuse to be... the worst player.
Right, channeling all of my lucky charms I had in my cereal last week.
Yeah, yeah, just pick Blade when you're up against me.
Just pick Blade.
What happened to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Gumi, go ahead and pick Blade.
My gun was like the big brain move.
Pick Blade when you're...
Don't be a rock, paper, scissors.
What if you have scroll?
There's no way.
There's no... I'm telling... I don't lie.
I tell the truth.
Just pick Blade.
What do you mean?
You don't even know yet.
You're lying to yourself.
No, I'm gonna pick Skull.
That's why I told you to pick Blade.
You can't pick Skull.
You get RNG.
Give it one.
Oh.
No, I get three.
No, they said they give you three and you get the pick.
That's if you're opposing them.
That's if you're opposing... if you're the opposing side.
What?
I don't... I'm... I don't...
Okay, so there's two people sitting at the table, yes?
Yeah.
There's two people sitting at the table.
One of them... you don't know who you are, but one of them gets given a randomized scroll, blade, or skull.
And the other person has to guess which one that person got.
Only one person gets to choose.
That's fucking stupid.
Not both of them.
Wait, my whole plan.
My whole plan.
I'm gonna take that as a yes you.
Okay, okay, when you're up against me, I will always tell the truth, Gumi.
You'll tell me?
Yeah.
I'll always tell the truth and you'll let me farm off of you so I won't get eliminated.
Yeah, you're gonna tell...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Eeyo.
Hey.
Hello.
Oh my god, my entire plan.
It's over.
It's so over.
It was just not clicking in your head.
You're like, what?
I thought it was just regular rock, paper, scissors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gumi, are you going into our lobby?
Do you trust us?
Yeah.
Wait, how do we pick colors?
Oh, you see around the map?
Listen, listen, Doki.
No, no, no, listen.
Yeah?
Wait, wait, wait.
We legit... we can team up, okay?
Like, we don't know who we'll play against.
It's 28 people per lobby.
Yeah.
We need a win.
We can farm each other.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's a text.
There's a text that the Minecrafters were telling me.
Yeah?
They were telling me, basically, you make an alliance and in your alliance, if you go against each other, whoever has more points, they lose on purpose to the person who has less points.
That's literally...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can say that in more complex words, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Alright, wait, what color?
Whoa!
Oh my god, we're in an infinite alliance!
Wait, wait, what color?
Where's me?
Close.
Doki, Doki, Doki, Doki, Doki.
I'm not last.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go this way.
Shut up, Sleepy.
Where do we go?
Wait, wait, we're trying to rally.
I'm so confused.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Sleepy's making me confused.
E-Rob, E-Rob.
Where do we go?
Which color?
We got a group, we got a group.
Where's Abe?
Where the fuck is Abe?
Where did Abe go?
He got lost in the massacre.
I don't know, I don't know.
Where's Guapo, man?
We all got lost.
Go in there, go in the pink.
Go in the pink.
Oh no, it's already over.
Oh god, they're filling up, guys.
They're filling up real quick.
Oh, we have to pick one color.
We gotta choose, we gotta choose.
What do we do?
We can't pick pink because...
Fuck, Abe, we gotta...
Oh, there's Abe, there's Abe, there's Abe.
There's Abe, there's Abe.
Blue, blue, blue, blue, go blue, go blue.
Blue, blue, blue, blue.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Blue is filling up though.
What if we don't make it?
Yeah, what if we don't make it?
We have to split up.
Okay, we split, we split.
I see you on the other side.
Okay.
All right, we're good, we're fine.
How many people?
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if I want to leave?
Wait, what if they have a bigger team than us?
Smoke me, I'm picking rock.
I'm picking rock.
Why can't we get in here?
Get in here, get in here.
This is my favorite.
Oh my god.
You can be, you can be mentally fortified.
It's not going to change the fact that I'm picking rock.
Okay.
Wait, go me.
What are you doing?
Sleepy.
I am.
I'm scared.
Go me left.
Yeah.
Get on the platform.
I'm not going to tell you.
You're not, you're not as fortified as I am.
Go me, go me left.
You, whoa.
I'm going to kill you.
Where did, where did go me go?
Go me, go me.
Are you not doing?
Yeah.
Oh, come on.
Oh.
What?
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
He's right.
Sleepy, sleepy.
Use two of your brain cells.
Hey, what the heck was that?
Who hit me?
What the hell was that?
Hey.
Look what you're looking at.
Oh yeah, we can stay here.
We can stay here.
Hey, hey.
I'm going to talk to you.
I need Reggie.
Oh.
You've thought.
You've thought about it.
Oh.
I was here before you thought.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hannah's on our team.
We're cool.
I don't know if you're whispering about something, but I can't hear you now.
I'm just saying we're good.
We're good.
We're cool.
Are we cool?
We're so cool.
What?
I think the other groups have bigger alliances than us.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
We're cool.
I think we're cool.
I think so too.
There are so many more people.
Are you in?
I feel like I know too many people.
Hey, don't get knocked out.
It's almost full.
Oh, are you in?
Oh, we're back in.
Hey, we're a team.
We're a team.
No beef.
I'm sorry.
I'm a little scared.
I got free.
They're kicking people out.
We have to do something like four and you've seen Mark and me like twenty times in a row.
Guys, stop it.
What?
We match up against each other.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of getting knocked out.
I'm scared of getting locked out.
I'm gonna read their minds.
I'm gonna crunch the numbers and do the math.
Yeah, Samuelson, you're gonna do all that?
Whoa, whoa, I'm not Samuelson.
I'm Sam's little brother right now.
Oh, what's your name?
Yeah, well, my name's Lil Sam.
Lil Sam?
That's crazy.
I mean, regardless, this is up to chance anyways.
Yeah, it doesn't get any better.
I was missing the first game.
He had to throw me off.
Every team's gonna have a bunch of faces we recognize.
How do we choose?
Also, I'm not gonna lie here.
The other teams we haven't checked out are all gonna have HPG, like a bunch of them.
What?
I said Rikkiu!
Oh, yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
I'll do the same.
Same shit, same shit.
According to the mathematics, you should average one point per game.
So if you're like 10 games in, you should have around 10 points.
I'm scared, guys.
I'm scared.
You know what I mean?
Because two for win, zero for loss.
Doki, there's a common evil.
There's a common evil.
If you're not at one point per game, come on.
Yeah, yeah, then it's...
As long as you're getting some.
Is it?
We have to make sure the women win.
I'm just saying that that should be the metric.
Oh, okay.
You and I are both women.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that means you gotta make sure I live through the next round.
You gotta make sure.
Girl, you can make sure of yourself.
No, no, this is a group effort.
Doki!
This is a group effort, Gumi.
Oh!
Hey!
I forgot, I forgot, I forgot that it actually hits.
Oh my god, that's fucked up!
That's messed up.
Yeah, I can't hear a shit.
I did not mean to hit you.
Gumi, I'm sorry.
Oh, emo only.
Don't worry, we already have emo only.
Oh my god, I'm sorry, I apologize.
Oh, because...
You win, I win, okay?
We can Fortnite.
Oh, oh, oh gosh!
I should try.
Eva!
I'm thinking, guys, when we face each other, do not draw.
I should have told everybody I'm gonna be completely honest with you.
Oh, goodbye!
Why do you get kicked out before the round starts?
Oh!
We have one minute, Abe, to get in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you want the one-time.
Like, if I'm going on...
Abe gets kicked out, you see, he's not in.
I got it, okay?
One minute left, Abe!
Oh, shit.
Don't pick off the latency!
Wait, it'll be, like, a free win!
Only five people in the elevator can keep out!
We're picking you off the TV.
One, two, three!
What happened?
You're not in the circle.
What is happening?
How does this work?
Yeah, he is in the circle.
When is the end?
Oh, you are in the circle.
We are trapping her!
And Abe's out of the circle!
Oh Abe, Abe you're being sacrificed!
I don't know what's going on!
What is it?
Good luck Abe!
Fifty seconds!
No we can't!
We just have to win two rounds!
Abe's gonna get it!
I'm gonna push you out of the door!
Three left!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I hope you're not going up against me!
Oh shit!
Well...
Hello!
So...
You probably want to know what item I was assigned, don't you?
Yeah!
I mean you wouldn't lie to me, right?
Wouldn't you like to know?
I'd love to know!
Alright, five gifted subs if you tell me what you have right now!
I actually developed a strategy!
You gotta listen to the mathematics!
Okay, okay I'm listening!
So on average, if you get at least one point a game, you should be fine!
But...
The outcome out of each round is usually two points unless we draw.
And if we draw, then the outcome is one point's net.
So if we just trade wins...
Yeah!
Oh that's so smart!
Yeah, yeah you wanna do that?
Yeah!
I'm gonna do it!
Oh my god!
You cooked me!
Sorry, can you explain again?
You actually wanna do that!
No, I got confused!
I got confused!
We trade wins...
So...
You won the first one...
Yeah, so then I let you win the next one, right?
Yes, and then you won the one after that...
And then...
I won that one after that...
I guess the last one will just stand up to chance.
Okay, yeah that sounds fun!
Okay...
I'm so serious about this too!
I'm so serious!
Tell me what you have, I will let you win again!
I will let you win again!
And then...
You let me win the one after that?
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, I have a blade.
I'm so serious!
You actually have a blade!
Why would I lie to you?
I'm so serious!
This is actually messed up!
Okay!
Oh my god!
Wait!
You lied to me!
Oh wait!
Okay!
I forgot I was letting you win!
Okay, I'll troll what I have now!
Oh, okay!
I actually didn't even... I have paper!
You have paper?
Yes, I actually have paper.
I'm not trolling.
You're actually not trolling?
So...
Yes, I have paper, so you go knife...
Okay!
Yeah, right?
That's how you go.
But like, what are you lying about?
You lied to me!
I swear to you I'm not lying!
I know I just tricked you, but I swear...
Wait, I thought you said it was an accident earlier!
That means you were purposely tricking me!
I'm actually just dumb!
Wait, so like...
Oh, now you're just dumb!
Oh, I see!
I'm actually just dumb?
I have paper, though.
Oh, okay.
So like, do we just wait?
Well, you choose...
You choose knife, right?
You choose knife.
Yeah.
Does that knife?
Oh, you did have paper!
Oh...
You don't trust me, huh?
I mean, you didn't trust me, too!
I'm actually an idiot!
I actually messed it up the second time!
You messed it up the second time?
Like, what do you mean by that?
No, like, on round two, I'm...
No, wait, no, on round...
I don't even know.
I don't know.
You know what?
Let's just make it...
Let's make it special.
Let's not... I won't even tell you what I have.
Because I actually didn't look, so...
I don't even know what I have.
Ew.
What could...
We could've worked together.
This could've been fine.
I mean, I did try to work together with you, but you didn't even...
You tricked me!
I will give you this one if you tell me what you have!
What I have?
I think I have paper.
No, I tricked you on the second one because I'm an idiot!
I think it was paper.
I don't remember.
Or was it rock?
I think it was rock.
It was rock or paper.
Oh, see?
You're a liar.
I'm gonna tell my group about you.
What?
I'm gonna tell my group about you that you're a liar.
I'm packing you up right now!
I think it was a lie.
Stop!
I love you!
He's a liar.
Please remember me.
I love you!
I'll get you!
Squid's a liar.
Don't trust him.
He's a liar?
Squid's a liar?
Don't trust Squid.
What about you?
Ducky.
It's what we talked about.
It's in the chat.
I'm not lying.
I know.
I told my group about you!
What'd you say?
No!
I'm sorry!
I appreciate you telling me.
I admit myself to be lying.
You just lied to me!
I need to be back in the room!
This is too loud!
You said Skrull and it was Skrull!
Are you okay?
That was way too loud.
Why is the intro so loud?
Did you win yours?
Squid's a liar.
Don't trust him.
Mimi's a liar too.
Mendo, who?
Mimi Lena.
Okay.
Pizza had to choose her.
We went 4-4.
I had the gut instinct that you were deceiving me.
Yeah, I got lied to.
I got 4 points.
I got 2 points though.
How much did Erob get?
Erob!
Wake up!
He's immune.
Did you win or lose?
Yes.
Good luck to us.
Who was it?
I got lied to.
I got 2 points.
Who was it?
Are you a liar?
You got me though, right?
I can't lie.
I have a problem.
I don't have any...
I can't do it.
Hey.
Oh.
Well, well, well.
Hey.
I'm 2 wins, 2 losses.
We traded wins and losses with my last person.
Oh, sweet.
Okay, anyway.
Don't trust Squid because he's a fucking liar.
Okay, I'm thinking about you.
I don't know who Squid is.
But I'm thinking about you and the person right in front of me here.
What item did you just get?
I got a blade.
I want to trust you.
Yeah, you should.
I'm very trustworthy.
But this first round is gonna decide how we're gonna do the rest of this game.
I'm willing to be trustworthy.
Okay, cool.
Alright, so I'm gonna lock it in with 10 seconds left.
Alright.
Doki, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I know you lost round 1.
Yeah.
I didn't lie about it.
Don't switch up on me.
Oh, wow.
You're actually being honest.
Yeah.
Now...
Okay, okay.
I need to be smart about this.
Yeah?
Are you gonna keep lying?
No, no.
How about this?
You know you're not gonna win the $70,000.
Who says?
Whoa, whoa!
You said something I don't like you!
Wow!
That's a loser's mentality right there!
And I'm a winner!
I'm gonna do it!
Wait, what item did I just get?
I think I missed it.
I don't know.
You've been assigned an item.
I can't see it!
Oh, there it is.
How did you see it?
You pressed F.
So I got...
a knife.
Okay.
So does that mean I get that round?
Does that mean I get that round?
If you skull, you will win.
Alright.
I'm putting that skull in.
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
Nope.
I just met you, but...
We just met, but you wouldn't lie to me, right?
I'm literally a bear!
Oh!
Wait, you're a truther!
I'm a truther.
You're a truther!
I told you I went back and forth exactly like this with my last person.
Okay.
Because all you gotta do is not lose everything.
Yeah.
You just win two and lose two.
You'll be in the middle.
You'll be fine.
You get through.
Okay.
Alright.
I have it.
I have a skull.
Deadass, you have a skull?
Yeah!
What's something you really care about in life?
I care about...
You have animals?
You got like a pet?
Whoa!
What are you do to my animal?
No, what I'm saying is I want you to put that promise.
Alright, if it's not a skull, I'll let you kill my pet.
In game.
In Minecraft.
Okay, I'm just gonna trust you because...
It's a skull!
We can get out of here alive.
Both of us!
See?
Oh wait, the timer's not up.
Wait, what?
I thought the timer... You have to wait until it's zero.
Mm-mm.
I would never lie to you.
I'm trusting you.
Nice.
And now my turn.
Wait, whose turn is it?
It's my turn.
What do you have?
Dude, this is crazy.
Because I've been getting knifed every single round.
I got a knife again.
Okay.
So I can put this then.
How much... Alright.
Alright.
What do you love in life?
I love my mother.
Okay, well...
I'm gonna build a statue of your mom.
In Minecraft.
If you lie to me.
And I'll blow it up.
Doki.
I love my mom.
So I'm gonna change my mind.
I said if you lied to me.
I have a scroll.
I know.
I love my mom too much is wrong.
Yeah, I would post that video up too.
On YouTube.
And you should check my channel subscriber.
And see how many people are gonna watch it.
I'm already subscribed.
It's a draw.
Okay.
So you did lie.
I lied.
You did lie.
I'm at 11.
Oh, that's good.
Are you like fully like...
I got 5 points.
Okay.
Did you vote?
I have 5 points.
How many points do you have?
6.
Who are you playing against?
I wanna get speed TMC.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, this is...
This is scary.
It's on the top left.
TinyMakda is cool.
I got 6.
BTMC is cool.
BTMC is not cool.
It's not cool.
He's not cool with you, Abe.
You're not cool with anyone, man.
Toki is not cool.
Wait, what do you mean?
I've been a true 3 this entire time.
I'm nervous.
Toki more like Dookie.
Wow.
Dookie.
Damn.
I knew I should punch you out.
I got 6.
I got 5.
Let's go.
I got 24 points.
Toki, you have 5 points?
You have 5 points.
How many points do you have?
I have 10 points.
What the fuck?
You've been lying to people.
You've been lying.
This guy is a liar.
I haven't lied once.
You should be proud of that.
You should not be proud of having 10 points because you're a liar.
I literally have not lied once.
He's lying to us right now.
He's lying to us.
He's not a good person because he's a liar.
Is it true, Abe?
People just don't trust you so you get a few points?
Yeah, I have 10 points.
I haven't lied once.
Everyone just trusts me.
I have the inverse effect.
No one fucking trusts me.
That's for good reason, man.
I'm not trusting you either.
That's true.
Oh shit.
Are you a truther?
I am a truther actually.
I'm a firm believer that what we should do is...
Round 1, I'll tell you what I have.
Genuinely.
And you can win one and then you do the same.
And I get to win one.
So first two rounds we don't play for real.
And then the second two rounds we'll play for real.
That'll be fun.
I have skull this time.
Yeah.
Like this?
Yeah, perfect.
And you wouldn't lie to me too, right?
No, I'm not lying.
You'll be willing to do it because you're gonna know that I was truthing this whole time.
I do have skull.
100%.
Oh yeah, skull.
Okay.
I trust you.
You seem like you're a mind-trappler.
I'm doing a lot of faith here.
I'm trusting you preemptively.
Oh, hey, you're right!
What did I say?
I told you I was a truther.
Yeah, you're such a truther.
I have a scroll.
I knew trusting Minecraft players was the right idea.
That's what I'm saying.
I have a scroll.
Okay, the scroll.
So I should go knife.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would never lie to you.
After we established our bonds.
Yeah, after I gave you that first one, surely we're gonna be...
Like we just met, you don't know my character?
Yeah.
Yeah, but I would never lie.
You gave me two points.
So why would I want another two points?
Yeah.
Why would you not want to also give me two points?
Yeah, exactly.
That's kind of fair.
Yeah, that would be so fucked up.
Then we can play for real, right?
Yeah, and then we play for real.
It would be so fucked up if I just like yoinked two points off of you like that.
After I gave you that free two points.
Like what kind of person am I to do that to you?
I would be heartbroken if that happened.
Yeah.
See?
Look, see?
I told you.
I told you I was truthing.
I would never fuck with you like that.
That's what I like to hear.
Okay, we're playing for real now?
Yeah, sure.
Okay, I...
Do you want me to tell you what I got still?
Sure.
Okay, I did in fact get the paper.
Oh, you got paper again?
I did.
What are the odds of that?
I've actually had paper the last three times now.
You had paper the last three times?
Wait, how many points do you have?
Yeah, because I had paper round one with you, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I had paper my last round against the other person as well.
Yeah, wait, how many rounds... how many points do you have?
Oh, I'm at nine right now.
You have nine points?
Damn!
Yeah, how many do you have?
Wait, that means people have been lying to you.
Yeah, people have been lying to me a bit.
That's so fucked up.
Why would they lie to you like that?
Ah, well, you know.
People be lying.
Yeah, you should get them banned.
For lying.
Get them banned?
Get them banned from the Minecraft event?
They're liars.
Yeah, liars.
Oh, hey!
Wait, you lied!
I was close!
I wasn't even running!
Okay!
Wait, so how many points do you have?
I have seven.
Oh, you have seven.
Okay, see, I'm at a comfortable ten right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, well, what did you get so I can give you these two points?
I have a...
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, give me those two points.
What happened?
Uh...
I mean...
I thought we were playing for real the last two rounds.
Yeah, but then you wanna lie to me?
Oh...
Oh... What's the thing that you love the most in life?
Um...
I don't know.
What's the thing?
Living, I guess.
Life is funny, you know?
Life is funny?
Yeah, it's a funny thing, you know?
Well, I hope you're happy living in hell.
Oh...
Oh, I'm drinking time!
Oh, no!
I hope you live with that guilt for the rest of your life.
I thought you were lying, so then I...
I'm gonna get your points.
Sprint, sprint.
I'm gonna get you, bro.
What's up?
Dude, you had my butt cheeks pucker in the whole time.
I'm kidding.
I have seven points.
I have ten points.
I got four points.
Okay, I need... I'm stressed out.
I'm stressed out.
I need to start lying.
Dude, you're on a roll, man.
I got lied to again.
I got lied to.
I got eight points.
I got seven points.
I need to start lying.
No, I need to start lying.
Kumi, you've been telling the truth.
Why the fuck have you been telling the truth?
You're losing.
I've always been telling the... because I don't tell lies!
That's not true!
I don't tell lies!
You literally lied to me 24x7.
That's not true!
You eat and sleep more and...
I'm always a true thing!
I feel like I lost three for all the last...
Yeah, me neither, man.
Wait, how many more games do we have left?
I don't know.
Like two?
Two?
Okay.
Wait, how many do you have, Dokie?
Six, I think.
Don't, don't, don't trust...
I got eight.
I got lied to.
I got lied to by Iskall.
And he's Swedish.
Wait, maybe he's a fake Swede.
Yeah.
He was going well and then he lied to me.
That's fucked up.
Why don't you lie too?
I might have to head to my lying org.
You have to start lying.
I gotta start lying too.
Wait, Gumi, we get matched up.
Like we have known each other for so long.
Like you wouldn't lie to me, right?
Yeah, I would never lie to you.
Of course.
What if you're lying right now?
I got, I've been tricked because I've been telling the truth.
That's why seven points.
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
No, it's bad because we were trading and he told me he had Skull and I said, okay, I like you, I'm gonna give you the win.
And I picked Blade and then he goes, no, it'll be a tie.
Dokie!
Hey, I've been having, no, I've been having a rough time because everybody's lying to me.
I'm not a liar.
Are you sure?
I think you promised.
I'm gonna tell you now that I got a knife.
Okay.
I put a skull up and I'm like, I promise I'm not lying.
Are you sure?
Wait, how many points do you have?
I got eight.
You got eight?
I haven't been lying but I had two people lying then I got a draw.
Yeah, I haven't been lying.
I have three points because they all took advantage of my truth.
What?
Yeah.
Everybody's been taking advantage of me.
Don't worry, I won't be lying to you.
Because I haven't been lying at all.
I don't lie at all either but I think that's kind of... Oh my god!
Thank you!
Now I have five points!
I told you.
Thank you!
That's so sweet of you.
I got you.
Don't worry, I won't lie to you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Can I have another point?
So I can stay in the game and then I'll give you the next two points.
Okay.
Yay!
Um, paper.
Oh...
Then I need to do school.
Yeah.
Thank you!
I almost did paper again and gave it a draw but...
That's so sweet.
I'll give you the points for the next one.
And then we should...
I would never!
No, I didn't!
I'm just saying if you do... I think I have paper.
Wait, let me double check again.
Yeah, I have paper.
I'm very forgetful too.
I've been lying later on after this round.
No, no.
I will never.
I will never lie to you.
I'm scared.
No, that's why I have three points!
Because people took advantage of my kindness!
I thought I had an alliance and then they abused it.
See?
Okay.
I mean like this round.
Oh yeah, yeah.
This round.
Uh, what do you have?
I got skull.
Look, see?
I never lied to you.
You gave me four points.
Oh, it did?
Nice!
Yeah!
I was trying to tell people earlier.
I was like, you get more points if we just do that back and forth.
We're together.
I know!
Like, I don't understand why people don't work together.
Like, it's so messed up.
It's Minecraft.
I thought Minecraft was all about like working.
Like, we're not even allowed to swear in Minecraft and people are lying?
Yeah, what do they think?
This is Among Us?
Yeah!
This is a Christian server.
God will not let you win!
This is not like this!
So the next one, do you wanna...
Would you rather just do like...
Like a wrong one rather than a plus four?
Yeah, we could just do like...
Wait, what do you mean by that?
You said plus... Oh no, no, no.
This is plus two.
Okay, never mind.
I misunderstood the point system.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Wait, is that the...
That's the last round, right?
Yes.
Oh, can I have two more points so I can not get eliminated?
Yeah.
Yay!
What do you want?
I am Blade.
Yay!
You're so nice.
Oh my god, you have been the nicest person I've like bumped into.
I told you, I won't lie to you.
That's so sweet!
I can't believe other people were taking advantage of your kindness!
I know, right?
That's so messed up!
I bet those people...
They're gonna go to hell.
Especially on Minecraft.
I know, especially on this Christian Minecraft survey.
You know they're never gonna win that $70,000.
You know?
You're taking it so seriously.
I need that.
Oh my god, thank you!
Is that the last one?
Or do we have another one?
No, that was definitely the last one.
Yay!
That's so easy.
Oh my god!
Guys, I got 13 points!
I got 12!
I got 13!
Mendo, how many you got?
I'm chillin', bro.
Mendo, bro, you gotta step it up.
I can't lie!
They'll feel bad if I lie!
You have to like take it.
I can't!
Oh my god, this isn't my new track, Guilt Tripping.
Who said that?
My new trick.
Mendo, I can't lie either, bro.
I can't do it.
What's your points, Abe?
14!
What's your points?
What points do you have?
I can't take that away from you, man.
You have 19?
Oh my god.
I can't even hear you.
You're so loud.
I suck at my spice.
Nooooo.
I can't believe it, guys.
I can't believe it.
I got 13 points, guys.
I might be safe.
Maybe...
Wait, is this the last game?
Yeah, I think it's one round left.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if it's us two?
How many points do you have?
That guy has 20!
14, I have 13.
I think we could be eliminated.
I think we might... I think we're...
I think we're fucked.
No, I'm sorry.
No, no, no, surely not.
I think we're fucked.
That's not a lot of points.
13's not a lot.
I'm sorry for lying, though.
14!
Guys, I'm scared.
I got taken advantage in the beginning.
So then I took advantage of somebody else.
But now, like, I feel like we're not gonna be able to make it, guys.
Guys...
Alright, Doki, good luck!
Good luck, good luck, good luck, guys!
Good luck!
Hi, Doki.
Hey, are you a truther?
I have been truthful with everyone I've played against.
Really?
How many points do you have?
I have 15.
15?
I have 6.
I've been truthful with some people.
No, I've been... people have been taking advantage of me.
Because I've been telling the truth.
You're a truther?
Yeah!
I got, like, squid in the first game.
And then he, like, took advantage of me.
And then I got some other guy.
With, like, a creeper thing.
A creeper skin.
And then he also, like, made me lose almost everybody.
So, like...
What do you have?
I have... I have a skull.
You have a skull?
Yeah.
Oh my god, thank you!
This is the way I've been doing it with everyone.
I give them the first win.
And then I go back and forth.
You don't have to, but that's the way I've been doing it.
Wait, can I have another point, though?
Because I might get eliminated.
Sure.
Yay!
Thank you!
I have a knife.
Knife?
Okay.
Oh, you put the skull.
You wouldn't lie, right?
Have you been telling the truth?
I have not lied a single time.
You haven't lied a single time?
Oh, okay.
You said you went against the creeper skin?
Was that sad?
They lied to me.
They kept lying.
Because they told the truth for the first two rounds.
And then they told lies in the last two rounds to me.
So then they won.
So they took advantage.
Because they were like, Because they were like, Oh, I'm going to tell the truth the entire time.
He was like, really?
So then I just trusted him.
Thank you!
Alright, I'll let you win the next one.
Alright.
See, I thought in the last game, this is where we were going to start seeing the real sides of people.
The real sides?
But you wouldn't lie though.
Yeah.
I wouldn't.
I have.
So can the last round, can I have the two points then?
So you get six, I get two?
Yeah.
Because you're in a comfortable place, aren't you?
I don't know.
Wait, what's your points?
Well, I had...
I've got 15.
Oh!
Yeah, no, you're comfortable.
I saw her, like some people, I heard it was like 12 and like 7.
So I think you're in a comfortable place.
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Okay.
Yeah, and I'm telling the truth.
I believe you.
Yeah, because you've been telling the truth this entire time.
I wonder though, how many people are going to do kind of what we're doing right now.
What, like exchanging stuff?
Yeah.
So it all kind of levels out at the end.
Oh, I know like there's some people with like 7 points.
So I think you should be fine.
That means there's got to be people with like 25, right?
I think the highest I heard was 20.
Alright, what do you have?
Even that's still insane.
I've got...
So are you okay if I take the last two points?
I'm fine with that.
Oh, okay, thank you.
What do you have?
Paper.
Paper?
Bye.
Did you ever play or did you ever watch uh... Splitter Steel?
Splitter Steel?
Wait, what's that?
Like any game shows where two people have to decide whether they like...
if they're given like money.
Oh, and then like you're like, oh if you pick the money up then you'll lose it for everybody like type deal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I never thought I'd be doing that in real life.
I know.
It's actually crazy.
I can't believe people are liars still.
Thank you so much for the points.
I really appreciate it.
How many do you have?
I have... I think I have...
You lost 15 minutes.
Guilt tripping.
I got eliminated!
You got eliminated?
How many points do you have?
No!
No way, no way!
Everyone's dead!
Wait, Sleepy, you got eliminated!
Sleepy, you got eliminated!
I told you, bro.
It's Lindo.
I can't lie to them, man.
I can't.
It's all thanks to you.
What?
I didn't do nothing.
How many points did you get?
Oh...
That is actually...
That is evil!
You're actually the villain, though.
I got eliminated.
I appreciate you.
No, please.
Sir, EROB lives!
For the next days!
Mendo, you have to EROB!
He's coming.
Oh, yeah, no, I- I touched you.
Oh, my god.
I can't believe it.
One more letter, Mendo?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Mendo, we went down together!
I trusted you, Sleepy!
And we did it!
We did it!
But it wasn't enough, man!
I can't believe it.
I made it to the next stage!
Guys, alright, turn off emote mode only.
Turn off emote mode.
We were six points away from getting it.
Oh my god.
Guys, if all else fails, it's guilt tripping time.
That was evil.
How is that even?
I made it through.
You're so going to hell.
Guys, I made it!
Let's fucking go!
I made it to the next round.
People gave me free points.
And I survived.
Let's do it.
Why would they scare me like that?
I'm dead.
I just gave you a twin.
I won, bro.
Look, I just lied.
It was just a little white lie.
Guys.
Just a little white lie.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
How many points did you get again?
18.
I got 19.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you know how I did it?
I guilt tripped it.
I was like, I only have three points.
Can I please have some points so I can stay in the round a little longer?
Oh my god.
So you did lie.
And then they gave me three rounds.
Both players gave me three rounds.
Did you die?
Did those players die?
No, no.
They didn't die.
Because they were already comfortable.
They were already comfortable.
So I was like, hey, you guys are going to make it anyway.
So like, can I have the three rounds?
I only have three points.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
I'm with you.
A lot of my friends lived.
Oh, nice.
I guess we're living to the next day.
Oh my god, Badoki.
Yeah?
I feel so bad.
I lied to one person.
But who did you lie to?
One point I lost.
There was a person who lied to me first.
And I was like, oh.
I want to go see who lost the last round.
And then I just lied to them at the last round.
Oh, they deserve it.
They deserve it.
We made it.
I thought it was funny that Mendo and Sleepy got kicked.
I know.
That's crazy.
I would have won.
Sleepy was so cocky too earlier.
He was like, I got the point.
Yeah.
I thought Sleepy was in for sure.
Yeah, me too.
I was not expecting his elimination.
Oh my.
Wait, what's the now?
It's time to decide your future.
What the fuck is that?
Dave got eliminated.
I don't know.
I wonder what that is.
Hi, Dave.
How many points did you end up with?
Yeah, how many points did you have?
You didn't save Mendo.
Oh.
Okay, whatever.
I'm going to win.
You didn't even save Mendo.
Oh, we woke up.
We woke up.
M, did you make it?
I did make it.
How many points did you get?
Use this to talk to other contestants.
Let's go.
We made it.
Last Easter egg.
Where is it?
Yay.
Find the last one.
We did it.
You see, people lie but rock what they had.
Skull, blade or paper or scroll.
I am at another level of lying.
I was at a different level.
Very evil yet very cool.
Nobody thought about lying to pull out the points.
I'm not going out day one.
No, I traded a bunch of them.
I had one round where I destroyed the game.
It's just twisted truth.
You traded all the way until the last one.
The last one was the person who lied to me.
Yeah, with everyone I was doing the first two we traded to each get two points.
This guy lied to me.
We can keep trading.
Yeah, he lied to me.
You lied to me?
I did not.
Yeah.
He did.
I hope you feel guilty.
I traded one though.
We traded the first two.
And then the last two we played for real.
Yeah, but then you lied.
We were playing for real.
The game is the lie.
Yeah.
Yeah, and the way I played the game was I was a truthful person.
Yeah, and you almost lost.
You started lying.
Yeah, he caused my joker arc.
I was a truthful person.
He corrupted me.
I was a truther until he corrupted me.
So I had to start lying.
I had to start guilt tripping people.
You had to do it.
No other choice.
My joker arc started it.
Oh, do not leave the server.
What are we supposed to do?
Yeah, I used to be a very trustworthy person.
And now people...
Now I have to lie.
No.
Yeah.
What do we even get for the Easter eggs?
I don't know.
What if you get a total drama island thing where you don't get kicked out?
Oh, like if you get all ten...
Yeah, but then everybody's gonna try and get ten then.
And then they can't kick out anyone after.
Yeah, but not everyone.
Look, you didn't try and get ten.
Yeah, but like now I'm going to try.
We have six days of this.
And the server...
And the server is like up like an hour...
Like more than an hour before the event starts too.
Because I logged into the server at like 11.
Yeah.
Wait, where are you?
I lost you.
I'm right behind you, man.
Oh, what the heck?
You're camouflaged.
I don't think there's any eggs here.
There's one over here.
Follow me though, Keith.
Oh, okay.
I only have one.
I haven't been paying attention.
Where's the call room?
Well, I could get eliminated tomorrow, chat.
The thing is, you can get eliminated at any day.
Oh my god, yeah.
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
Is there an egg here, guys?
Yeah, there should be, right?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, where is it?
Does anybody know where the tenth egg is?
What?
Stand where I am.
Stand where I am and then up.
Oh, snap.
They're selecting people for tie breakers.
Jump, Doki.
Jump.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, there's tie breakers?
It's right here.
Apparently people tie it with coins and then they're gonna duke it out.
Wait, is it like a...
Wait, how do we...
How do we like find it?
Oh, yeah.
I hit that one.
Oh, I had 19 points.
So like...
No, no, no.
Tie breakers are for the people who weren't in our room.
Oh!
Wait.
Our room was the only one with no tie breaker.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
There's two in this room, Doki.
Oh, okay.
Where?
There is a TV over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it.
Wait, have you found all 10 already?
No, no, no.
I only found 8.
Oh my...
And then there's another one over here.
Okay, I have three.
I wonder if we can watch the tie breaker.
I'm gonna be real.
I know Dr. Gluon is like...
I mean...
We're not allowed to leave yet.
We should be allowed to watch the tie breaker.
Oh, chat.
I don't think I have any more.
Well, you're allowed to, Chris.
If you watch the stream.
Wait, we can't watch the tie breaker.
Oh, we're over.
How many points did you have?
I had 16.
I almost got somebody eliminated though.
Because they were like, what?
17 or something?
They literally just...
Pat lived.
Oh my god.
I'm nervous.
How did we do this?
I could have let them die.
And then one right here.
Oh, okay.
Now I have 7.
Wait, how did you have 8 then?
Where's the eighth one?
Wait, where?
What tree?
Contestants will compete in our battle.
Where was the last one you got?
Oh, over here.
People said there's some outside.
Yeah, we got the tree outside already.
Oh, wait.
Is this the same outside?
Oh.
Yeah, there should be more around here.
Oh, are we gonna watch them?
I don't know.
Oh, we're right here.
Yeah, I got it.
Alright, let's see if we watch them.
Oh, wait.
I guess we watch.
Oh my god.
I got so scared.
I thought I was in tie breaker.
That was so cool.
Guys, write this down.
We're gonna steal... I mean, borrow this.
For our own stuff.
For our own...
Hey, Goomy, where are you?
Stelky, where are you going?
Oh, I'm here.
Guys, write this down.
We're gonna...
You see, people are running with particles.
If they have a particle, you don't want to be near them.
You just need to run away, you know?
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm actually gonna pee my pants.
I'm actually gonna pee my pants.
I'm wet.
The sound effects are so scary.
Oh!
It's like Crab Game.
Go, K, Go!
It's just like Crab Game.
You know, with the stick?
Yeah, the hot potato.
Go, K, Go!
Nice.
That is not enough time.
Go, K, Go!
That is absolutely not enough time.
Oh, there's no way!
Good shoot!
Oh!
They left!
That is not enough time.
Yeah, it's like 20 seconds.
It's so crazy that you got through with 16 points and Open Water lost and I think he had 17 because Green was so competitive.
You gotta dodge.
You just shift to the blue.
Oh, no.
Come on, Silverman.
I'm just so scared for him.
So, do you have to try and hit the other player while you have the...
You can't even see.
Yeah!
The curse is consumed.
Oh, like invis, invis, invis.
Oh, I guess like one elimination criteria met.
Wait, who lived?
I feel like anyone that got like the curse lost automatically.
Because that was so brutal.
Yeah, I feel like if you have the curse, you just automatically lose.
No.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, map's too big and the time's too short there.
I hope they adjust that.
It seems pretty unfair.
Guys, I did not expect to make it to Day 2.
I thought I was gonna have like a one-week vacation.
Well, I mean like...
Most likely I'll be eliminated on Day 2.
I don't think I'm gonna...
No, you're fine.
You're fine.
You got 30 seconds.
You need to track them the fuck down.
Like...
Maybe...
I feel like I'm gonna get eliminated.
There's no way I'll live past the second day.
These guys are Minecraft players.
Find the tenth egg.
Ooh, you're right.
Wait, another one?
There's another tiebreaker?
I don't know if you guys knew, but I could hear you and I heard all of you guys.
Oh my god.
There's another... Okay, guys.
Do you guys know where the Easter eggs are?
We're gonna try.
Oh my god.
So many tiebreakers.
I know.
I already discovered this.
Multiple teams needed...
Multiple teams needed to...
Oh, I thought that was like everybody.
Oh, I guess cause like each color had tiebreakers.
Guys!
Stream snipe time!
Where's the last... Where's the last TV?
Yeah, for each color.
Oh, cause ours was the... was the one that didn't have the thing.
Bottom...
Guys!
Bottom right is not an answer.
Bottom right is not an answer, guys.
Bottom left, Toki.
Shit, you're fucking right.
Let me go check bottom left.
It's over there.
It's there!
Here!
Up there!
Disempate numero 2.
I don't understand why we had to have emote only.
If we didn't have emote only, you guys would have fucking broke my...
You guys would have fucking snitched me out.
On the guilt trip.
You guys would have 100% snitched me out.
Oh my god.
No, we already got that TV.
We already got that.
He's right here.
You've got the silver!
I've no idea who these people are, but I guess I'll cheer for...
Good luck, y'all.
I'll cheer for the first person I see.
Run!
It's in your name.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, bro, there's no way he's gonna chase... He has 20 seconds to get to him.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
He's so far away, my render is gone.
He's so far away.
My render distance doesn't make it.
Oh my god.
Chosen...
Vios.
Yeah, look at...
Everybody knows.
Where is Silva?
Oh!
Wait, he actually caught somebody!
She did it!
Oh my god, the first person to catch somebody!
I'm scared.
Oh my god, the very first one.
There they are.
I don't think there's enough time for someone to get somebody out.
I don't think Silva has it.
Yeah, everybody.
It's to be... This game mode is...
Wait, they didn't test this, surely.
Surely they not?
Streamers not testing stuff?
No way!
Let's go!
That's it?
That was so fast.
Did we get anything for that?
That was so fucking fast.
Real.
Thanks so much.
You're the best.
Streamers actually testing video games?
No fucking way.
Kratos!
Oh my god.
Nah, there's no way.
Maybe there should be...
Maybe there's a TV in the bedroom.
Do you think there's TVs in the bedroom?
We literally are missing like one TV.
We got all the other TVs.
We're just missing one TV left.
Check the graveyard?
There's a graveyard?
Wait, there's a fucking graveyard?
Yeah, I wish we had like the invisible flying.
I think the invisible flying.
Graveyard?
Oh, the purple portal!
You can go through that?
Okay, let's check it out.
Let's check it out.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's head to the portal.
We have two more.
Wait, I might be like the last VTuber.
What's this?
These are everybody that died!
Right?
No, who the fuck are these people?
There's no way.
Wait, that's me!
I'm dead!
Oh my god!
I'm secretly a ghost!
Alright guys, I don't think they're in the graveyard.
I don't think the TV is in the graveyard.
Guys.
Yeah, this is everybody's...
Oh, the ones that didn't make it are like a tombstone.
Oh, I see!
The ones that didn't make it are...
Wait, they didn't teleport us!
Is it because we're in the graveyard?
Wait, I didn't get teleported!
No!
Oh, wait, no.
They didn't start yet.
I'll never find the last...
What the fuck?
It was so fast!
Who are the two people that are alive?
They told us not to disconnect, so...
So I'm like...
I'm like being a good person.
Actually, Hax!
No!
They said don't leave!
So I'm actually listening!
There's no way!
He's not gonna find him.
Bro, he's not gonna fucking find him.
Bro, he can't even find him!
That's so fucked!
It's so fucked!
He doesn't even know where he is!
Another VTuber.
Another VTuber gone.
Oh, wait, unless...
Oh, unless...
Oh, no, no, that's the...
This is so rigged.
I know...
I wish we could like fly.
Good job, good job, good job.
I can't believe you survived!
I did!
Good escort!
I think I'm like intruding.
I'm definitely intruding.
I'm gonna go get some food.
Oh, nice!
He lived!
Woo!
I'll never find the last Easter egg.
I'll never find it.
I'm glad it didn't.
Where the heck is the last TV?
How was I supposed to know?
Oops.
I think this last egg guy actually scrambled it and it doesn't exist.
In the end...
I hope everybody that lied to me and started my joker arc does not win...
does not win Top 20.
Holy shit!
He's so fast!
I hope they don't win.
I hope they wasted their time and they get eliminated on Day 4...
I hope they get eliminated I'm living in day 4 because that's a cutoff when the money stops.
When the money just starts going in.
That's all I care about.
That's so evil.
All those people that started my joker.
There's like two outside here.
So there should be two outside the other area.
It's not a waste of exposure.
Yeah, but it's not $70,000.
You know what?
I hope one of them was just barely set.
Like they get second place.
So they feel like shit that they didn't win first.
I already discovered that.
God, that sucks.
When they barely missed out on the $70,000.
That's what they get for lying to me.
No, it's like top 20.
So I think like first is $70,000.
Second is... what is second again guys?
Do you guys know what second is?
Because I don't remember.
I just know first is $70,000 because it's fucking $70,000.
And then $12,000?
Okay, second is $70,000.
Second is like $12,000.
And then third to 20th is $1,000.
Wait, Gumi found the last Easter egg?
Wait, where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
Where is she?
Are you sure you're in?
Yes, I'm 100% sure.
Because the person that I guilt tripped was lower points than me, but they made it.
That's why I know.
Top right guys.
Which outside?
This outside?
The other outside?
It has to be this other.
Oh my God, I love this guy's skin.
No, I was so close outside.
I was so close.
Oh wait, that's not the outside.
No.
Oh, I just saw Gumi too.
Oh, it's that outside.
Okay, now we know where the TV is.
I'm glad we got through this day.
Okay.
I literally don't know how to go over this group, so like...
Nice.
I'm gonna take the high ground.
Wait, Twitch says no outside.
Ask for coordinates.
Show your coordinates, Doki.
Find the coordinates.
Apparently somebody...
Yeah, yeah.
Hey.
Silver, if you have like, if you have a potato, do you have it at all?
No, I didn't.
Can you say shout out to...
I just got lucky.
I don't even think you...
Shout out to who?
It's so...
Fuzzy Snugs.
Can you say that?
Fuzzy Snugs?
Yeah, Fuzzy, like, you know, like Fuzzy, like, you know...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, what's in it for me?
What's in it for me?
You get to make somebody happy, I guess.
Is this a cameo?
Yes, yes.
Cameo?
Okay, follow me on Twitter and I'll shout him out.
What's in it for me?
For me?
You know, like...
Wait, I'm doing a favor for you!
I'm doing a favor for you!
Listen, there is no incentive for me.
I just said, so very simply, somebody in my stream chat is a big fan.
Yeah, and I'm doing you a favor.
Not me a favor.
I don't care what happens, okay?
No more!
Yeah, like, so you hate your chat.
You're not allowed to follow me on Twitter.
It's one click.
Yes, actually, I do.
I definitely do hate...
It's one click.
I definitely do hate my chat.
But you can't say two words.
It's one click.
You can't say, ah, shout out Swizzy Stuggs, shout out Jesse.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you see?
Now who's the big person now?
Hey, that's in your chat.
That's not my chat.
Yeah, okay, listen.
Listen, okay?
Listen, I don't know who you are, but apparently they do, okay?
So, you know, what's in it for me?
It's one click.
Oh, you're not willing to do one click just to...
I don't do much things.
I'll never learn.
I'm not...
Damn, that's fucked up.
He's not willing to...
He just showed up.
Thank God.
He showed up to snoke.
It's a snokey post.
So rude.
Why am I the rude one?
They...
They asked me for a shout out.
I was like, alright, one click, follow me on Twitter.
Just one click, two words.
It's a good exchange.
I give you a...
Two words, one click.
Clicking is free.
Yeah, clicking is free.
It's a good exchange.
Yeah, click, follow me on Twitter.
Yeah, equivalent exchange.
It's a good exchange.
It's just business.
Yeah, you didn't even have to stay follow.
Hey guys, if you're from SonicFox's...
SonicFox's chat, I would never do that to you.
I love my chat.
Right, tragoons?
I will never do that to you guys.
Look where I'm standing.
Where is the TV?
Here!
Walk right here!
Is there a TV here?
Right here.
Put it down!
MAMMAR!
Yeah?
Where is it?
I can't see!
Where is the TV?
Guys, I need...
Guys, I need you guys to translate!
Yeah!
Where is it?
Oh my God!
Finally!
That's crazy!
Wait, I see it!
Yeah!
Oh my God!
I followed the Minecraft!
Translated!
We did it!
We got everything!
We got everything, guys!
Perfect game!
We did it!
Yeah!
Oh my God!
That one was hard!
That one was fucking hard!
Alright, let me see.
I'm gonna check.
I'm gonna check if he followed.
This is important, guys!
We gotta know!
I'm gonna see the ones outside of this.
There's one in the tree and then there's one in the other.
They didn't follow!
No!
No shoutout!
That was broadcast on the main Rylos channel.
Oh, the... us all fucking bunching up.
That entire conversation!
Wait, really?
Wait!
That entire conversation I had?
No fucking way!
Oh my God!
I can't believe it!
There's no way!
Oh no!
I got exposed!
I want the hair.
Damn.
I got exposed.
Exposed.
I'm showing the world.
What do you mean?
They...
They literally said, I hate my chat.
So I... it caught them in 4K.
It caught...
They got caught on 4K.
And I was like, whoa, I would never...
I was like, whoa, I would never...
Oh, hey!
Hey, guys!
Ready to play Valorant?
Oh, yeah.
I almost forgot about that.
Yeah, you can never forget about it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Right now.
I need to get... get lunch first.
And then I can play.
But I'll be playing.
I won't be streaming it though.
Okay.
You get lunch first and then we can play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it over yet?
Like, what are we waiting for?
Yeah, it's over.
Oh, okay.
Cause like they never said you're allowed to leave now.
Oh, like, don't be!
I got all 10 eggs!
Oh, me too!
I found it!
Yeah!
What the heck?
You found all 10?
You found it in the dark?
Yeah, the last one's at the dark.
Wait, how many do you have, Ant?
I have 8 right now.
What the fuck?
You just started laughing!
I have a crazy laugh right now.
Wait, what about us?
I have 10!
What happens now?
I don't think... it's just nothing.
It's just like bragging power.
By having 10, you get to laugh at people who don't have 10.
Like that.
I know one that I didn't get yet.
Maybe we'll get that one.
There's one outside that's really fucked up.
Yeah, come on.
Is it like in a tree?
Cause I didn't get that one yet.
No, it's really fucked up.
It's really fucked up.
Alright, I'm gonna go grab lunch.
I'll see you later, Gumi.
DM me, DM me!
Alright, alright.
Alright, guys.
We made it, guys!
We made it today, too!
I can't believe my whole conversation was put up on stream.
We made it!
Good time interacting with people I haven't interacted with before.
Yeah.
And...
How dare!
And I had a good time just talking to people, and like...
Okay, the first...
The first one...
The first one was really fucked up, though.
I think the first game was super fucked up.
That one was messed up for me.
I can barely play the game and it took so long.
It took so long!
I can barely take in anything that was going on in the first one.
And I felt like that should have been much shorter, 100%.
But the second one was fun.
The second game was really fun.
I think the best part was just interacting.
Nobody expected me to make it to the second game.
But we did it.
Yeah, I was running a goddamn marathon.
I was running a goddamn marathon in the first game.
And I was like, please, let this be over.
And I was doing it wrong.
I was doing the marathon wrong too.
Because I wasn't holding space.
Because I didn't know the Minecraft tech.
The second game was fun.
I had a great time in the second game.
I still can't believe Mendo and Sleepy didn't make it through.
What the fuck?
They were so confident earlier.
JokeyBird was born today.
But yeah, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
I think it's the same time.
It's the same time tomorrow.
And there's also two games.
So we'll see if we get eliminated.
But anyway, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
I'm all ready to go.
Since I'll be showing up after lunch.
After I get food.
But anyway, guys.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get a bit more around.
Get that blood.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Or I don't know.
Stay up for Valorant.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Oh shit.
Never mind.
Let's take a group picture.
JK.
I want to be part of the group picture.
Exposure.
Wait.
Mainstairs?
Okay.
Guys, we got to get the exposure.
We made it to day one.
They're going to post a screenshot.
Bro.
The Minecraft streamers are going to post the screenshot guys.
Pre-exposure.
Yeah.
I'm going to sorority crouch.
Yes.
Sorority crouch.
Okay.
The worst part is that I actually don't have a costume.
Wait.
What's up?
What's the...
To show you guys what I'm wearing.
Guys.
What the fuck?
F5?
Is that F5?
Alright.
This is my skin.
Uhhh.
Yeah.
Thank you.
This is nice to see you guys.
I want to be TP.
Picture.
Take a picture.
For me.
I'll be brown bear now.
Picture.
Photo.
Say Queso.
Queso.
Oh my god!
Jigs!
Holy shit!
That was so loud!
Yeah, sorry guys.
Sorry guys, that was really loud.
I was like, what am I supposed to look?
I don't understand!
I looked away!
No!
I didn't know!
Alright, but yes, this is me.
Yo, yo, can we disconnect now already?
This is me.
This is my custom skin.
You can also get the skin just like this.
This is actually my OG skin.
I've had this skin for years.
I've actually I've had this skin since I had a Minecraft account.
So it's like actual OG.
It's not like I put it on.
It's not like I put this on like 3-6 months ago.
I actually had this skin like for the last 5-6 years.
I've always been a bear.
So I never changed it.
I've never changed this skin.
Just another skin suit.
Alright, if anyone wants to make a custom skin for me, it has to have the qualities of the bear skin.
It has to have parts of the bear skin, guys.
That's all I ask for.
It has to have some qualities of this.
Guys, that's all I ask.
It's like, it's part of the part of my lore.
I've always been a bear.
Before the skin suit, I had a bear skin suit.
But not in a furry type of way.
I'm just saying.
It was just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft, guys.
I just thought it was cute.
Just in Minecraft.
Alright guys, now I actually have to go now.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!